everybody we're going to get going here
welcome to 2024 Municipal and County
government going to start with the
Pledge of Allegiance we're going to ask
please I pledge alance to the flag of
the United States of America to the
Republic for which stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
for
all
okay represent McDonald Mr clerk will
you call the role
please he Mr chairman uh representative
power present representative
Guthrie uh clerk is here representative
lales here represent
Ella representative Kelly
representative awood here representative
Brown here representative kahill here
representative
stavis here thank you representative
Tatro here representative T
Len uh representative
Gilman represent majori representative
Gallagher representative Hicks here
representative Howland here
representative priest here
representative
frus and Mr
chairman pres and representative Guth
you okay once again again good morning
everybody Welcome to Municipal and
County government for
2024 uh just a couple comments before we
get started here with our bills um the
first thing is of course most people in
the back already know this but if you
wish to speak make sure you fill in a
pink card and give it to uh
representative lales on the end who will
pass it to representative Brown and then
get those up to us please do not uh walk
up in front here um if you're just here
to sign in for or against use the uh
blue sheets uh reminder other than water
in here uh that there uh no drinks are
allowed and uh no food in our U
Committee hearing
rooms for our committee for those who
are here um we have close to 50 bills
this session so we're going to be very
busy again um I think you all got the
message regarding my obligations on a
couple Wednesdays a month so we they're
not going to be every Wednesday this
term so I'm going to ask you to pay
attention to uh notices and always the
calendar the calendar will always have
the days that we're meeting um as far as
January excuse me uh next Wednesday
which is the 17th we will be meeting the
following Wednesday the 24th we will be
meeting and then the uh last Tuesday of
the month which will be the 30th we will
be
meeting so 17th
24th and 30th that'll be our uh January
um watch there may be an additional day
thrown in where we do some exing or I
really haven't planned out the last two
uh weeks of our January yet but uh pay
attention to that so with that we're
going to go ahead and open up our
hearings today we're going to start with
hb180 relative to the scope of the
homestead
exemption representative Wallace welcome
to Municipal and County government
you're the first one up this year well
thank you chairman turkot and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is representative Scott Wallace
Rockingham County District 8 the town of
Danville um I'm here to introduce House
Bill 1180 which uh was I was prompted to
file this bill in response to a consumer
consumer uh alert issued by the uh
Department of Justice um regarding
Homestead rights for non-titled spouses
there was a recent case that came forth
um that kind of turned previous uh
decisions with respect to uh Homestead
exemptions and bankruptcies and deaths
of a spouse um and this went all the way
to the New Hampshire Supreme Court and
then it was appealed to the local
federal court at which time a common law
or a non-named spouse on a deed was
excluded from uh a homestead exemption
uh in the case of a bankruptcy or a
death of the spouse this bill is quite
simple it would repeal the existing
paragraph in law and make language
changes so that it would be quite clear
as to uh that each spouse uh or owner of
the
property has that right to claim the
homestead exemption in those particular
cases um it's as simple as that pretty
straightforward I'd be happy to take any
questions okay thank you
representative are there any questions
committee representative
svis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um what would
happen in the event that a surviving
spouse receiving the this homestead
exemption um inherited a major
Fortune is there
any mechanism in this bill that would
check the status of that person and
whether they continued to qualify uh
thank you for the question that's an
excellent question um I'm not prepared
to answer that as I don't believe
currently that is considered for the
homeset exemption as things um as a case
courts um representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question so I'm seeking some
clarification on lines three and five
with regards to the claim clim it says
uh on both lines it says the homestead
right as to
$120,000 on both lines and the word as
is unclear to me and I'm wondering if up
to
$120,000 is more
appropriate uh representative thank you
for the question um that may be this was
drafted um in uh myself and uh
representative
Lynn drafted this language together and
um the language that was that is put
forth was his language so seeing his um
or considering his past um history uh I
I went with that seeing he's had to
historically representative priest thank
you Mr chairman for uh taking my
question thank you for being here uh
could you explain again what is the
current policy or regulations as it
relates and why is this important sure
um at this point in time what has
happened historically was basically
upended in a recent case that went all
the way to the Supreme Court
historically if you had a um a common
law couple and one and they entered into
a bankruptcy situation um if you were a
married couple each individual would get
a
$120,000 exemption uh towards the value
of that uh property in a homestead um
but the the current statute is quite
vague and the uh the federal court
interpreted that because it was not
perfectly clear that each uh each
property owner individually and
separately gets get that claim um they
denied the claim and it went to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court which upheld the
federal Court's decision so this is to
clarify that in the event that uh uh
whether it be a a common law couple or
conventional husband and wife or a civil
union each individual ought to have
those rights to their protection of
their Assets in a bankruptcy or a death
situation representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative you keep using the term
common law does New Hampshire have
recognized common law unions or
marriages or rights um I'm not exactly
certain on that it's it's it's kind of a
gray area I believe there is a after a
seven-year period I believe there are
some rights afforded um but the purpose
of this is to provide protection for
individuals that don't have a
conventionally blessed if if you will
Union of some sort but yet their rights
still exist and this would uh provide
protection for
those okay thank you you're
welcome representative
majority thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I I know the
existing law says and you carry it here
that every person um but then in the
next sentence it says the spouse of an
owner and I'm just curious if if that
specifically can only be the spouse or
can it be one of the
owners and I'm not sure that I'm not
sure that makes perfect sense I was just
curious because there it gets very
specific to only the spouse but in the
sentence before that there can be
different owners do you get my point yes
thank you for the question uh I would
agree that u in s some circumstances you
might have multiple you could have a
dozen owners of a particular piece of
property but the Homestead Act is
clearly designed to protect a husband
and wife or a civil union couple type of
a situation not a corporation or other
um you know a limited liability
thank uh representative
Howland thank you for taking my question
so I just want to clarify so the same
rules that apply for you to Grant the in
what already is existing the $120,000
exemption those would also apply to the
whatever the additional now
$120,000 uh exemption uh in other words
I think that's to what representative
stavis said if you had like a local to
qualify for the exemption you had to
make x amount of money or you had a cap
on that the same rules apply under this
you're just doubling potentially the
amount they could ask for in the
exemption that is correct we're just to
make this is just to make sure that each
party is protected yeah the and I'm
sorry if I'm jumping in it's a just a
followup on that it's it's like so in
other words the the municipality still
has the ability to say no to the
exemption and to control when they give
the
exemption this is not going to address
any of those other areas just
the uh specifically uh naming who is
eligible for the exemption it doesn't
affect the way that it is uh approved or
disproved just who's who's entitled to
claim this exemption thank
you representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank
representative for taking my question
I'm going to follow up on uh
representative howland's question and
just simplify it that in the bill the uh
Homestead right is 120,000 for each
individual correct so and annually it
could be 240,000
well this is a one time only this would
that is not the case this only would
happen in the event let's say
hypothetically speaking you've got a um
a husband wife and they're not able to
make their mortgage payments their house
is worth
$500,000 they've got $300,000 in equity
the bank forecloses they are able to as
current law has it they would only be
able to protect
$120,000 of the equity in that property
um even though they're married or if
they're in a married situation they
would be protected but if they were
unmarried and they both contributed over
the years one of them would not be able
to claim that exemption only the named
individual on the deed this would
provide um an additional $120,000 to the
other
co-owner um which is the spirit and the
intent of the law and the ACT nationally
but this is a hole in our statutes as we
Hampshire any further questions
representative
Lal yes thank you for taking my question
um the figure of
$120,000 do you know how long that has
been
active I do not but we not I'm not
seeking to change the the the amount of
the exemption uh but I did provide a u a
link to
um the various Homestead Acts throughout
the country and New Hampshire is we're
probably in the mid to lower end of the
spectrum some states have no limit some
states are as low as 15 000 But to
answer your question no I don't know how
long it's been there but it's been quite
some
time follow up Mr chair followup I'm
just wondering if we should take
advantage of the opportunity to update
that figure if indeed it needs to be um
I would be open to that and I would
suggest that perhaps the committee
should take a look at the link that I
sent and uh you know see where we're at
presently see where we might be able to
go but uh it might be a an opportune
time to ratchet that up a bit thank
you representative stavis thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking yet
another question anytime um just to be
very clear this homestead exemption does
not apply to property
taxes no thank
you further
questions seeing none I have one
representative um
somebody mentioned about how basically
how many individuals can claim on a
property I think he answered that my
other question is couldn't all of this
be avoided by simply ensuring that the
name was on a
deed that is
correct however uh in some instances
myself for example I owned my home
before I was
married okay so when I got married I
took the I took the time to put my wife
on the deed to ensure that she's
protected but people can get busy and
they might not consider that so this is
designed to lay that groundwork so
somebody has protection should they fail
to consider
that thank
you for the
questions see none thank you very much
representative thank
you uh I do not have any other pink
cards and I have a blue signning sheet
with one pro and that was
representative Scott
Wallace so with that we're going to go
ahead and close the
hearing and looks like we got a couple
one
representative
savis your question you said it does not
apply to something and I did not get the
that
you
e we should go first and you
probably
from okay it is 10:20 we're going to go
ahead and open up the hearing on House
Bill 10:34 relative to enabling
municipalities to adopt a homestead
property tax exemption uh before I get
going uh we had figured only about 20
minutes on this bill we have a lot of
pink cards I think every one of them
except one is in favor so uh I'm going
to ask
that after the uh sponsor introduces and
talks about it if you have something to
add in addition I would ask you to do
that do so but make it brief please uh
we have a lot of bills we got to get
through today so uh just no repetition
please and if things start going too
long we'll we'll go to a three minute uh
maximum with that uh representative
Paige Pa thank you Mr
chairman so my goal here today is a goal
that I would hope all of us share which
is to reduce the property tax burden on
our everyday
families and I'm here to Advocate on
behalf of my constituents in
Conway and for everyday people in towns
like mine where Market Dynam ICS are
pricing local people out of communities
where they have spent their entire
lives here in New Hampshire we pride
ourselves on being a low tax
state but there's one area where we've
lagged our New England neighbors and
that is in passing a homestead property
tax exemption to provide tax relief
needed by local
people the bill before you today would
provide a local option for
municipalities to exempt a portion of
the assessed value of residential real
estate from taxation provided that the
property is used as the applicant's
principal place of
residence the exemption would be adopted
pursuant to RSA 7227 a following the
same procedure as our existing
exemptions and critically the bill
you're considering today is strictly
enabling
legislation and I want to be
upfront and acknowledge that this
exemption is not going to be the perfect
fit for every
Community but even if it's not the fit
for your
community it's a Lifeline that my
neighbors in Conway
need Conway is a great place to live and
as many of you probably know it's a
great place to to visit but living in a
great place to visit is a double-edged
sword vacation home buyers and
burgeoning short-term rental industry
distort our local housing
market nearly half of our property tax
bills in Conway are mailed out of
Conway nearly a quarter of our
residential real estate is used for
short-term rentals
a local option Homestead Property Tax
exemption is a vital tool in our tool
kit that would Empower municipalities
like mine to ensure local people can
afford to keep living keep working keep
thriving in the community that they
love so just a few weeks ago Conway
completed our reval and since then my
neighbors
have been writing to me daily I'm sure
my fellow Conway reps can attest to this
they've been getting it too and everyone
is expressing their shock and concern at
their new property tax bills so
following our reval the tax bill on an
average single family home went up
25% but on a mobile home a whopping
75% 75% increase in one
year so meanwhile tax bills on local
commercial properties have signic ific L
decreased so the tax burden in Conway is
Shifting further and further onto our
lowincome residents this is enormously
Solutions one great advantage of a
homestead property tax exemption is that
delivers relief where it's needed
most the greatest tax relief benefit
flows to those owning lower valued
properties and the benefit phases out as
you reach the top of the
market we need to stop balancing Our
Town budgets on the backs of those least
able to afford it but the sad truth of
the matter is we currently can't do that
we just can't our hands are
tied with this exemption municipalities
like mine would have the ability to
deliver relief to our neighbors our
friends our elders our young families
just trying to get started and keep them
community the Need For Change is
urgent the status quo is unsustainable
and unless we find Solutions swiftly the
prob the problem will only continue to
snowball as more and more local people
pick up
sticks and see their family homes
properties I want to take a moment to
acknowledge the concerns that some may
have regarding the potential costs
associated with implementing a homestead
exemption so there's no hiding from the
fact that when you reduce taxes for one
group under an exemption you're raising
it for someone
else and I would again just emphasize
the important fact that this is local
option
legislation in Conway for example we
have the support of many many business
owners for this exemption because when
they saw their business tax bill go down
and their tax bill on their home go up
they were scratching their heads just
like everyone else and they saw the
Injustice of it on its face so this is a
decision for each Community to make as
we seek to achieve a sustainable
community that balances the needs of
local folks
our tourist industry which we
value as well as other businesses in the
community but right now we simply lack
choices I also want to acknowledge that
there are going to be some local costs
to
implementation among these costs are
likely software updates which I've heard
estimated in the ball park of maybe
$5,000 in Vendor
fees uh additionally there's likelihood
of Staffing costs to the municipality
associated with the additional time
needed for
administration but again I'd emphasize
that this legislation is strictly
enabling each Community has the autonomy
to decide for itself whether incurring
those additional costs is justified by
the benefits of providing meaningful tax
relief for local
residents lastly I want to acknowledge
that there are many many many different
ways to structure a homestead
exemption and as a prime sponsor of this
bill I don't pretend that my way is the
only way so I want to say Point Blank I
remain
flexible eager to work with anyone who
wants to help me find a solution for my
constituents and open to Amendment on
this bill I've already been working
closely with nhma over the last several
weeks to address uh technical concerns
that they have raised such as the need
to address pration more clearly in the
bill in cases of fractional ownership
and shifting our method of calculating
the cap on this exemption from using an
average to a median to control for
property value
outliers that that amendment is in
process and I'm happy to share it with
you
today I'm also eager to work with you
all in committee to resolve whatever
additional concerns you might raise
today I urge this committee to consider
action on this issue this year and I'm
eager to collaborate with all committee
members and stakeholders as we work
together to find a solution that ensures
meaningful property tax relief for local
families for my community and for others
like mine it is Mission critical that we
prioritize the financial stability of
our residents especially our most
vulnerable
residents and take proactive steps this
year toward a more fair and sustainable
tax system
thank you for your time and
consideration and I look forward to
working collaboratively with members of
committee to advance this
legislation thank you for your testimony
any questions from the committee
representative
Gallagher so I believe we had um a
similar Homestead um property tax
exemption bill before us last term that
I believe it was representative Reed was
the Prime sponsor on uh I'm wondering if
um you're familiar with um her bill from
last ter at all and if so if you could
um compare um yours with hers at
all sure I I am somewhat familiar with
it um this legislation shares some
features with it and differs in other
ways I'll say that one um feature of
that legis ation was that it had a fair
Fairly elaborate system for means
testing I will say if means testing is
something this committee would want to
pursue I'm open to discussing how to do
that in a way that isn't too
burdensome my feeling in drafting this
bill was that a homestead exemption is
already by Nature Progressive right
because your your greatest tax really
flows to your lower valued properties um
so in you you know one legislator's
opinion that additional um burden that
we would be be placing on administering
the exemption was not worth sort of the
tradeoff further questions represent
major thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um given given
the circumstances in Conway and I bet
this is similar in many other
communities how do you you envision the
definition of a
principal or or principally uh principal
residence by by some time that you live
there given that you have so many
short-term rentals sure
um in the bill it's there is a
definition of the term residence I think
to some
extent
um so the way we've defined it here is
which in which the person uh in good
faith regards his home to the exclusion
of any other places where the person may
temporarily live if you would advise
that we tighten that up I would
certainly be open to that
suggestion um it is nhma has also
suggested that we bring in a length of
residency requirement in line with the
elderly sort of parallel to what we do
for the elderly exemption I am very open
to that and I have put that into the
well representative Holland thank you
for taking my question excuse me so is
it is it Revenue neutral in other words
the amount of exemptions that you give
to your community exactly theoretically
matches the increase that you're doing
to your short-term rental and then kind
of on that same note um I'm asking that
because could you take some of that
extra money and then utilize it because
it seems to be one of the cruxs of the
problems of of Conway is the decline in
value of your commercial uh properties
and therefore it's like Shifting the
burden more on the residential so while
you could give exemptions to tax relief
the other would be incentives to kind of
bolster your uh commercial core to kind
of balance your taxes out a little bit
better sure so I heard one question and
one idea I guess the answer the answer
to your question is yes it's Revenue
neutral and the my response to your idea
is I love that and I'd love to have that
conversation
so thank you repres
br hello representative Paige uh I've
I've actually spoken to representative
Paige at length about this bill a number
of times and uh I'm very sympathetic to
what he's trying to do but I guess uh
for the committee a couple of questions
I had was what is a perspective like
representa Howland was talking about the
the view from the business owners and
and having to balance the tax rate
between them and the lower cost people
um what are the feelings and have you
review that specifically with them sure
I wouldn't want to speak for every
business owner I'm sure there's a
there's variable opinion and probably
your opinion somewhat depends on whether
you also live in town or not um I will
say that there is certainly a lot of
sentiment in the business community in
support of this effort I wouldn't
pretend that it's Universal uh but
there's certainly support we just had a
letter to the editor in the paper the
other day from a business owner um
saying how unjust it was when they got
these two bills and how it didn't make
any sense to them so I I wouldn't say
it's uniform but it's I don't think that
the business Community is going to come
out against this bill hard in our town
people need workers people's workers
need a place to live um so I think PE
people understand that people understand
large
initial question Mr follow up uh in
regard to what you had said earlier kind
of along the same lines but U you
mentioned the uh the rates for the the
lower cost homeowners like U mobile home
type people lower cost what have the
selectman's view been on this and in
that you said their rate went up 70% I
mean some of this could be handled just
on the rates for different types of
homes in the town couldn't they
since I have three or four of my select
board here with me I would defer to them
when they speak on that question thank
you see no more questions thank you very
much for your testim thank you thank you
Mr
chairman okay um as I was bruising
through the pin cards I note that uh six
of the remaining eight are all from
Conway and I suspected from the
beginning this might have something to
do with the Str issue that's been going
on up there so I'm going to ask you once
again um if you are going to speak and
you're from Conway if there's anything
in addition to what representative Paige
said please do but please let's not go
down a repetitive testimony so with that
I'm going to call
uh
I am Bill Marvel from uh South Conway we
like to call it um I will just
corroborate what David said um on a
personal basis I come from a family that
tends to be
sedentary um for three and a half
centuries they were in one Village in
England and for eight Generations in a
corner of Sussex County Delaware and now
for five on davis hill in South
Conway um I live 600 yards from the
house where I was conceived and I sleep
in the same bedroom I was given when I
was 5 years old and I hope to be carried
out of that house feet
first the recent uh increase in taxes
for me although it wasn't as bad as for
many uh challenges that hope U taxes
have all always been a problem for those
of us of modest income uh and now it
grows more
impossible um at a recent meeting I had
the pain of watching a 37-year veteran
police officer now in his 80s uh who was
a mentor to us as children having a hard
time controlling his emotions as he
explained that he might not be able to
survive with the taxes he now has
therefore I hope that rather than
finding an excuse to uh put this off for
another session uh that you will find
some means to help carry it
through uh where it's so badly
needed thank you thank
you seeing no questions thank you for
your
colbath good morning um yes I'm John
colbath a lifelong resident of Conway
born in Memorial Hospital lived there
all my life although I have got out of
town I have four college degrees from
colleges in New Hampshire and two
graduat uate degrees from a college in
Boston I was fortunate to be a
well-educated
professional worked for the State of New
Hampshire for 25 years in the North
Country um I am a I'm in my ninth year
as selectman in the town of Conway and
I've been a
longterm member of the Zoning Board of
adjustment and the current chairman of
that board um I first want to address a
little bit of clarification on the
reassessment in the town of Conway as
you know it's required every four years
the valuations of the town are supposed
to be properties between 90 and
120% and we try to strive for the 100%
currently the valuation of the entire
town is at
99% previous to this businesses
commercial properties were paying in the
120 range and residentials were as low
as
55% so part of the reassessment is to
equalize that and in the current
structure commercial properties did go
up
24% so there was some Equalization there
so commercial properties did not totally
get out out of their tax burden there's
always problems issues concerns business
owners citizens long-term residents with
any reassessment and we're going through
that process of sorting it all out right
now and hopefully doing it in an orderly
manner I want to speak a little bit
about my mother who was a long-term
resident of Carol County was a
professional nurse also was very active
in local POS politics last 25 years of
her life she moved to Bradenton Florida
she owned two homes there and she was
able to live comfortably because there
was a Homestead Act in place which
helped her tax burden I represent a lot
of constituents who like me are aging
and we wish to age in place we want to
stay in our homes and we need some
relief from tax burden we know about the
tax structure of the State of New
Hampshire there's no higher level taxes
so we take it on the chin with property
tax in a place like Conway like other
towns I'm sure with aging populations as
you probably know Carol County's the
oldest aging county in the state and
that we need tax relief from doing it
and this this bill would help people
again age in place and stay in their
homes for a longer period thank you and
in parting I want to thank all of you
for the town you represent in doing the
job that you do I know it's not an easy
task and I as a resent and taxpayer of
this state appreciate what each and
every one of you
do thank you thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
T oh did I see some yeah represen
VI thank you um I'm not sure how
uh uh my questions are a little bit
technical trying to understand the
situation um being proposed um
how do you know how much uh the
valuation of the
business um the valuation in Conway is
and versus the uh valuation the total
valuation of residential and how how
many units or uh Lots each of those
those uh are in your municipality and
how would that would um so an honest
answer is no okay that's but I'm sure
some of the people behind me we could
get any of that information to you and
there may be people behind me who do can
answer that question but I cannot okay
no worries thank you thank you for your
testimony uh up next we have
Holmes
I'd like to thank the committee for
allowing me to speak today I've spent
most of my adult life as a property tax
professional 10 years as assessor in
Beverly Mass Meed my first house in
1981 uh moved to Conway in uh 1994
became their tax assessor for 23 years
uh during that time he became very
active in the assessor Association here
in New Hampshire serving most of its
functions including one year as its
president I was appointed to as a
charter member to the assessing stand
ERS board by then Governor jeene Shaheen
and reappointed 3 years later by then
Governor Greg Benson I say all this so
let you know that I think I'm delivering
informed opinion on this issue I've done
over 15 to 20 revaluations in various
communities in Massachusetts and and New
Hampshire and um my opinion is that this
is the single most important piece of
legislation for property tax relief to
New Hampshire residents that I've ever
seen in my opinion is superior to
broad-based taxes rooms and meals sear
charges or the Massachusetts style
proposition 2 and a
half um what Conway is there are
Regional forces at work that control
Conway's real estate market and other
tourist attractive towns in New
Hampshire uh Conway has no control or
its residents have no control over their
property values uh people uh for one of
a better word are coming up with bags of
money driving up prices in the since we
came out of the last Great Recession um
Realtors have told me that more out
ofate people are buying real estate than
local so locals are priced out of it and
not only that but they're paying cash
many times asking price many times above
asking price when they get into bidding
wars and even professional couples in
Conway I think of one uh who emailed me
at one point with pre-approved for
$300,000 mortgage and could not buy a
home because out of state people are
paying cash so the buyer the seller
doesn't have to wait for inspections
doesn't have to wait for appraisals it's
like here a bag of money let's close
this has resulted in um revealing a law
that's also a feature in Pro in Conway's
property tax system in that they're
required to revalue every 5 years and
every five years there's a reset to
market value for all classes of property
unfortunately the real estate action on
the residential side including the
demand for short-term rentals uh has
driven up property values and Conway 75
to 100% over the last 10 years
residential I the commercials Walmart
not so much it's harder to double the
price of a Walmart I believe the the the
uh the
number uh was the average increase was
either 25 or 45% for res for commercial
and 75% for residential mobile homes
going
100% I just want to point out five
properties to illustrate the issue these
are well-known National Commercial
chains Walmart's tax bill in 2022 was
271,000 in 2023 $182,000 a reduction of
$888,000 Home Depot was 99,000 reduced
to 146 a reduction of
$53,000 McDonald's was 32,000 reduced to
22,000 a reduction in
$10,000 Hampton in
153,000 down to 8666 minus $34,000 and
LLB 1177 92 down to
85132 and I believe these numbers are
correct I believe the assessor did a
pretty good job statistically I haven't
done a deep dive into the individual
sales but just those five commercial
properties represent $219,000 decrease
in commercial property taxes none of
which goes uncollected it gets shifted
to homeowners that's 218 families seeing
a $1,000 increase and it's a heck of a
lot more than five commercial properties
in Conway so I'd like to thank the
committee once again I'd like them take
seriously this bill I'm available to
answer questions technical questions I
was assess for so many years and I was
the town manager for the last five
before I retired in 22 thank you thank
you for your
testimony seeing no questions thank you
misho thank you committee members for
the opportunity to testify today my name
is Jim misho and I'm the town assessor
for Hudson New Hampshire um I did have
written testimony but I think I need to
uh modify it and um if there is an
amendment that's going to be made to
this bill I would ask for a second
public hearing um there's a lot of
details to administering the homestead
exemption uh Massachusetts has it uh a
number of states have them Massachusetts
has it up to 35% of a property value um
which is kind of similar to this
one um looking to the proposal itself uh
this's a section that deals with annual
adoption by the
municipality so the question is what if
the municipality forgets municipalities
do forget things what if they forget to
put on the ballot does the homestead
exemption go away I don't know what if
it fails on the second year does it
revert to the first Year's value or does
it go away I don't
know um something about the um way tax
rates are calculated is optional
exemptions are not exported into the
county tax rate process so there's an
RSA that would need to be amended if
this came into play um and that's RSA
2-j colon 3 section 13 and basically it
ignores the Exempted value of your
optional exemptions so um so as to not
distort a county apportionment on a per
municipality basis so that's a technical
part um the amount of the homes that
exemption available shall be a fixed
dollar amount determined annually by the
municipality pursuant to uh 7227 a and
shall not exceed an amount equal to
35% of the um assessed value of
residential property in the community
35% of what so we vote in March before
the new tax year starts I think it
should be clarified to say it's 35% of
the prior years's meeting assessed value
right but in a revalue year you would
want to add language it says in example
of a full reevaluation you want it to be
35% of that reevaluation year
so in a non- revalue year you'd know in
March what your prior year was but in a
revalue year you won't know what your 35
up to 35% is until you get done with the
reval and you're scrambling to get the
ms1 in and it's September because you
have to have the value of the exemption
arrived at in some total for the whole
Community for all the exemptions prior
to going to setting the tax rate right
you have to put on the ms1 so there's
some um timing aspects to the
important um it states that it is
applicable
to each Homestead so so if I'm married
is it my Homestead and my wife's
Homestead is it two homesteads per
property I don't know um is it just on
single family property itself not a
single family with an L is not a single
family property right that's it's two
units is it single family property mixed
use right so it's got some commercial
got some single family I don't know
there might be some clarification in the
bill that speaks to that but I'm much
more comfortable when it's when it's
really clear right because a community
needs to administer this the same
throughout the state and every community
that adopts this speaking to that this
passes into law it's local option what
communities will not adopt this every
Community will adopt this that do any
kind of um commercial industrial base
that has any kind of second home base
the tax shift that Conway's been
discussing that's been going on in every
reevaluation but it's been magnified
since the year 2020 in Hudson we did a
reevaluation last year we didn't have
the same kind of tax shift but we had a
significant tax shift from commercial
industrial property owners to
residential so I think one if you put
this in the law you just got to be
prepared for what's going to happen and
of course property tax taxes will
increase on those properties that don't
receive a homestead exemption second
home owners apartment buildings do
apartment buildings pass on costs to
their tenants would rents go up I don't
know um commercial industrial property
business owners um this town has the
homestead their taxes are this high does
that mean they go to another to another
Community does the business leave that
employs people that work in that
community so there's some policy issues
that really go beyond just one Community
it's really kind of a Statewide question
what kind of Homestead do you want um an
excellent source for Homestead
exemptions and what is done in other
states is the Lincoln Land Institute of
land policy in Cambridge um the
principal uh I won't say researcher the
principal person dealing with property
tax there is Ron Raco and he's the
commissioner former commissioner of the
Boston assessing Department he's an
excellent source if you're going to have
any kind of um work session on this or
you're going to have a study Commission
on this or something like that so
there's definitely resources that you
on implementation costs I think were
address briefly um certainly software
changes right to the the mass appraisal
system or to the tax collection system
um certainly Staffing they pointed to
that you know it's one thing to track
the residency of a thousand or so
veterans credits that I have in Hudson
and about three or 400 elderly exemption
disabled exemption blind exemption right
all have residency requirements it's
quite another to track thousands right
think Manchester thousands right it's
not just Conway a lot of communes are
going adopt this um in other states that
have Homestead exemptions and I think of
Florida because they often contact us
they have entire divisions in their
County assessing off County Appraisal
offices that deal with policing
Homestead exemptions that were granted
in error human nature being what it is
people are going to apply for this
exemption even though they may not
qualify and the community may not have
the resources to um you know go to core
logic or go go to other databases to
determine is that person really a
resident so in other states they have a
clawback mechanism that enables the
state to go back on the person for the
years in which they got the homestead
for which they were not entitled we
don't have that in Hampshire for any
exemption or credit we have to find it
within the tax year once the new tax
year starts we don't have the ability to
back bill so it hasn't become really an
important issue right because we're just
dealing with exemptions and credits and
it's only a small percentage of
community gets that gets them it'll
become much larger when you have
homestead exemption something to
consider um that's the extent of my
testimony I would be interested in you
know looking at any amendments that come
in um it's it's a signif significant
issue I agree with Tom Holmes it is
probably the most important issue
dealing with property taxes that this
committee will address this year thank
you thank you
uh representative
Brown so uh Mr misho uh are you for or
against this bill I speak to the
administrative aspects of it so my Huds
and board of slackman have not taken any
position on the bill so I I'm here just
to what about the bill would make it
difficult to administer at the local
level what about the bill um is could
cause changes in the State uh or within
my own
Community follow up Mr chairman follow
up so in principle you think it's a good
idea I think I need to see more details
to see if that principle could be upheld
okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr misho for taking my question um I
represent Lebanon which has um an out of
proportion number of not
for-profit
properties um
our tax rate went up considerably this
year U mostly on residential homes I'm
my question to you as an assessor is in
communities such as Lebanon or even con
or any community in New Hampshire that
has an outsize proportion of properties
that do not pay at the level of single
family homes how will those
municipalities pay their bills should
this become law it's Revenue
neutral can you it's Revenue neutral if
if we're going to increase the
rate and those that don't get the
homestead will now pay on that increase
rate they will pay more taxes those that
receed the homestead exemption will get
less taxes if I understand your question
follow Mr followup repres I'm sorry but
is that in this
bill that's the Practical implication of
working out the impact of any exemption
elderly disabled blind Homestead repres
question thank you any further questions
before you um did you say you were going
to submit testimony after you redraft is
that correct thank you that would be
helpful uh one question I have would it
be fair because I've heard
different stories
on Commercial versus
residential assessments up down whatever
would it be fair to say that on a
Statewide basis in general not 100% of
the cases in general that commercial
properties assessed value have risen at
a slower rate than residential yes thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testim thank
colbath
good morning uh thank you uh for hearing
me today I I don't have nearly the uh as
impressive Bona feed days as my father
um but I did stumble into local Politics
as well I am the uh chairman of the
planning board in Conway and um the uh
issue at hand uh I don't want to repeat
what's been said already but as a public
official I get a lot of people asking me
what can be done what what's what's this
what are we doing at the Town level to
help with the housing issue and with the
citizens and um if you look at the New
Hampshire zoning Atlas Conway has some
of the most permissive Zoning for
housing and for um long-term housing
long-term rentals and we constantly are
trying to work at the planning board
level of how to keep people in town how
to keep people in houses how to make it
affordable to live in the valley um
unfortunately um with the short-term
rental situation it has become rather
unaffordable to live in the valley and
some relief for the citizens is is
needed and it's needed for the
businesses as well we rely far too much
on j1's to come to the area to staff the
restaurants and the ski mountains and
because our communities are empty our
houses are empty I live I was born and
raised in Conway I live in a
neighborhood where when I was in
elementary school that's where you went
to get a pillowcase full of candy I mean
the the houses were all full of families
and people and now the community I live
in is more than half short-term
rentals and it's disheartening and it's
frustrating and um it is completely
skewed the value of our homes and my tax
bill went up more than
25% and
it's just I I don't know what else that
we can do at the Town level to help and
I'm here because it just seemed like the
next thing to do I I also represent
families I have five kids on Thursday
I'm driving my daughter to
UVM um having to pay more in taxes is
not helping with her tuition um I'm a
blue collar worker I had to take the day
off to come down here and do this I
think I probably am maybe the only Blue
Collar person in this room and it's not
easy for people like me to get down here
and testify to stuff like this but it's
what people like me need and my
community so I hope that uh you
seriously consider this and uh thank you
for your time thank you any questions
before you leave thank you for coming
down we do appreciate those who do take
the time and effort to come down and and
speak uh one other thing I did make um
mean to mention representative Brown
kind of hit on it uh we know up here if
you're for against or neutral on a bill
the rest of the audience and our
committee does not so when you first
come up to testify would be helpful you
said I am I'm in support I'm against or
I'm
neutral uh next we have Carl
Tibido no
is good morning uh C tibo Vice chairman
of col Board of selectman testifying in
favor um some of what I'm going to start
off with is a little repetitive but I'll
get to the point uh this bill provides
much needed tax relief to those who can
least afford the large tax bills uh due
to the recent economic conditions
property values and Associated taxes
have skyrocketed and people came here
from a away paid well over asking price
for all types of residential real estate
resulting in a shift in assessed value
that is unbelievable a manufactured home
in the park excuse me went from an
average of 47,000 to 125 resulting in
tax bills doubling or tripling in the
meantime commercial property went up
only modestly resulting in a $90,000
saving to the local wall at uh this is
result is that it's now upside down and
this bill is needed desperately to
correct that um here's the new
information our full-time residents are
persons that are primarily working in
the tourist industry and tending retail
facilities uh that's what the town of
Conway and the surrounding area relies
on uh there are those lobbying against
this bill to say it'll be bad for
tourism and second home real estate
market and I believe believe that the
opposite is true passage of this bill
will help the tourist industry in the
long run by allowing people to stay in
their homes and be able to work and
maintain the continuity of the tourist
industry today we have hotels that are
unopened others operating at reduced
capacity as well as restaurants that are
closed two days a week for the lack of
adequate staff it'll only get worse if
the working folks are taxed out of their
home and no one will be left to staff
hotels restaurants shops and the
property maintenance company that take
care of all of this our three bordering
states have homestead tax benefits and
it doesn't appear to have discouraged
any economic activity in any of them and
in some cases it actually helps to
attract full-time residents who can
anticipate uh A Better Tax situation and
we need to have more of this to fill the
jobs that are currently going unfilled
for lack of people it's time to get this
done so the residents can afford to live
here continue to thrive here and work
and I thank you for your
time thank you any questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony sir uh last
up uh
Paul
dangel good morning thank you for this
opportunity to speak um did I understand
you correctly I'm last up you are so
that means that all of these um folks
who spoke so well and eloquently that
came before me means that these notes
that I prepared are no longer useful so
instead excellent thank you for your
testimony next now go ahead he's here
all week
folks um my name as we just established
is Paul delang I'm the deputy Town
manager for the town of Conway I've been
employed by the town of Conway these
past 33 Seasons I've seen a lot of
change uh I haven't seen anything like
the change we've seen in the last three
years uh since the anomaly which you
probably refer to as the
pandemic um before I get started in the
points uh that I want to touch on that
we've heard others say um Katherine heck
asked me to apologize to the committee
she had to leave to give testimony
elsewhere as you know she is within hand
Municipal Association uh there are some
Representatives that probably know that
the municipal Association was opposed to
the bill in the past because of
technical issues and she would uh she
said that she would reach out to the
members and speak to you directly um but
asked me to say that they are officially
neutral on this and they are looking
forward to the
amendment and um I believe that's all
she wanted to
convey
um what I no is that we've heard from
two uh very experienced seasoned
assessors one from Hudson one from
Conway my good friend Tom Holmes who I
worked with for many years and they both
agree that this is the single most
significant legislation that could
help people who live and work in their
communities again this is a local
option um we heard some questions about
technical
issues we believe those can be worked
out in the amendment so we're looking
for you know the committee support to
keep that alive so we have the
opportunity to do that work uh we've
heard that we have surrounding states
that do this so clearly this can be
accomplished if Vermont
Maine ver um Massachusetts and Rhode
Island can do it so good New Hampshire
so thank you again for that I do want to
point out that this is not an Str Str
issue this is a second home issue now
I'm not going to disagree that strs
maybe were the the difference that
allowed some people to afford a second
home but this is an issue that we
believe was uh for two reasons one we
are a Resort destination Community
therefore we're desirable to be there
some folks decided it was time maybe
maybe it was the pandemic that was their
Catalyst but these are affluent folks
affluent enough that they can afford a
second home they're not necessarily Str
strs we heard chairman colbath of the
planning board say that there are empty
neighborhoods that's true so they're not
being short-term rented these folks
bought a property because Boston is only
two hours from where they work right
they're working in places that afford
them higher rates of pay more fluent
communities but this is where they want
to be and that's why they're there uh
not an Str issue it's a second home
issue and yes we have many homes that
are sitting uh
vacant
earlier while listening to Mr uh Holmes
give testimony I I I thought I was in
the wrong committee I thought this was a
committee for legislation to have
separate commercial and residential tax
rates which of course New Hampshire
doesn't have nor are we suggesting so
this vehicle this is the vehicle that
helps folks who it's this is their
primary dwelling right this is the this
is the vehicle that helps
multigeneration families hang on to
their homes I also hope that bill Marvel
will be able to be carried feet first
home now Bill no
editorial um I hear in my capacity as a
deputy Town manager from everyone I I
live in the community I'm raising
children I have a child in the high
school one in the Middle School one in
the elementary school I coach skiing and
I coach baseball by the way our town was
the the u12 Championships this year in
New Hampshire thank you very much and
who do I hear from I hear from veterans
I hear from retired policemen I hear
Farmers our free market economy means if
you have the money to pay for more you
can if you have the money to buy real
estate without financing you can if you
get winded that you're losing the bid on
this piece of property then you can
raise your money whereas the school
teacher could not because they were
seeking
financing we ask you for your support we
ask you for the opportunity to work
through the technical issues the
administrative issues we believe the
time has come for this local option in
New Hampshire thank you very much thank
Kella thank you uh thank you for taking
the
question
um it looks like according to Conway's
uh uh valuation that they posted on on
their website that there's um about $700
Million worth of um
business and about
2.5 uh
billion in in uh
residential um and the average
valuation um is about
350,000 uh dollars so that talks uh up
to the 35% would be
$140,000
exemption um it seems like um most of
the property um
is the shifting is not actually to
business so much as it is to the other
$24,000 uh uh homes so I guess have you
run I guess my question is have you run
any numbers and and found where uh a
person a homeowner uh reaches that break
even point where they're going to be
caught uh actually paying more uh if if
Conway was to adopt this scheme than
uh than they are
now you know I'm not I'm not sure the
analysis or the approach is um how we
would approach it again as as I said
earlier New Hampshire's not a state
where we have separate commercial taxes
and property taxes so the consideration
of the distribution and the value of the
commercial to the residential is not
part part of the analysis the analysis
is if you're living and working in
Conway if this is your primary dwelling
can you for can you expect to get some
tax
relief as opposed
to uh the folks who invested had a
second or third home and who paid above
market
prices so it's a
redistribution
of of capital now that redistribution as
you know is across the whole board it
doesn't go from this part of the
residential to that it goes across
whatever the value is left the shift in
the values is all based on the market
had commercial been strong but that's
not what happened even if it didn't you
could make an argument that you would
still want to
afford
your your primary dwellings your
residence in any Community the ability
since they made the choice to live and
work in the North country where they
don't have the opportunities for as much
disposable
Capital so your analysis is not
something that was jine to the factors
that drove us to ask for this
bill does that make sense to you what
I'm saying we don't
have questions only go one way here
representative Brown so um you're the
deputy Town manager correct yes sir okay
so um based on a little bit of what
representa said and I was thinking about
this and you touched on a little bit you
haven't figured out how you're going to
do this correct how would this work how
would this
um this homestead exemption work in your
town to give to give the relief it seems
like you haven't um developed a plan if
this was passed do you understand what
I'm saying well I don't is I said it
it's it's working in these other states
we're working on the amendment we're
working with the municipal Association
which is uh for the first time not
opposed to the bill and I'm certain that
we can uh address the issues from the
assessor from Hudson um that's where
we're
at
we like everyone in New Hampshire is on
you know on deadlines and we're we're
working that if we move this to
Amendment then these are your questions
and we can come back if we can have
another working session then we can
questions one more followup then we need
to move on so just quickly so where
would you see the burden being shifted
what what areas because you talked about
commercial and residential and how the
need goes to lower income people where
would that be shifted so because the
whole tax has to be shifted to other
folks right so we've heard heard about
three three sectors the
Homesteader the non-homestead
residential and that which is
commercial so it's shifted from the
sectors you're welcome okay seeing no
more questions thank you for your
HB were we on HB 1034 so I'm going to
close the hearing on that thank you all
that
okay um those of you who are still in
the room not for this next hearing if
you could please vacate and have
discussions outside that would be
helpful I'm going to go ahead and open
hearing
1154 gentleman at the table could you
please cease discussions thank you uh
1154 relative to property tax exemptions
veterans representative power Vice
floor it's written okay it's backwards
thank you Mr chairman committee members
I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today House Bill
1154 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline m in Greenville in Hillsboro
County District 36 to begin I will
address the background of this bill this
bill was filed upon the request of the
office of the adant General State of New
Hampshire Department of military Affairs
and veteran
services this is a straightforward Bill
intended to
clarify the intent of the existing
statute the current statute has been
found to be confusing in its
interpretation as well as
application as a result both veterans
and M municipalities erroneously believe
that some veterans qualify for this
property tax exemption when in fact they
should not
qualify this ambiguity also carries the
risk of the exemption being mistakenly
granted moreover this leads to a
patchwork of
application across the state due to
municipalities interpreting and applying
this law
differently again the intent of this
bill is to more precisely
clarify eligibility
Criterion thus making it easier for both
veterans and municipalities to
understand the law as well as for the
municipalities to correctly and fairly
Grant this property tax exemption next I
so as you can see um in lines 4 through
7 there is language that is struck and
the following additions are are made
first in line 8 a reference to RSA 21
colon 50 replaces the above struck
language and this aligns this section of
the law with the new Hampshire's
statutory definition of a veteran second
languages added in lines 8
through2 that clarifies the eligibility
requirements that a veteran must own a
home that had been adapted through the
VA through this through e either the
approved specially special adapted
housing sah Grant or a special home home
adaption sha
Grant alternatively a veteran must in
order to qualify and be eligible they
must own a home that had been that has
been specially adapted and this home has
been acquired from the sale of a
previously owned home that had been
adapted by the s or sha Grant and third
language is added in lines 12 through
13 um specifying that a surviving spouse
shall no longer qualify for the prop
this property tax exemption if they
remarry and this provision is completely
consistent with qualifications for other
military state and federal benefits for
surviving spouses which veterans and
their spouses should be very familiar
with and lastly the um in line 14
officer is is struck due to the addition
of the reference to in to the definition
of a veteran in 21 colon 50 and back in
line eight so with that Mr chairman that
concludes my bill introduction I'm happy
to answer any questions but in perhaps
in the interest of time um more
technical specific questions might be
deferred to um those from
the from the VA who are here to testify
understood do we have any questions for
representative power representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question
um in in line nine it says that um
someone who owns a home who who which
has been specific specifically adapted
by the Veterans Administration um does
that mean that the Veterans
Administration has to be the contractor
or um like I I don't see how this um
like wouldn't it be better to say like
it was um through through funds
approved uh through the uh these
programs
and wouldn't that be more clear thank
you representative um that's a very good
question and I do agree that that
language is a little bit vague the
language was given to me um by the
department of military Affairs and
veteran
services and um I'm open to
clarification in an amendment if that is
needed and I would ask um I don't
believe that that the VA needs to do the
Contracting work but we could clean
clean that up in an amendment so you
might want to ask the others who are
here to testify after
me thank you representer
brown represent power I had a similar
question my my question is I support
numerous veterans organization including
tunnels to Towers which do these types
of things for for veterans so uh along
the same lines to say by the Veterans
Administration or some other
organization that might be providing
these funds that would still meet the
criteria uh that's shown in this uh
document so I I really think we need to
clarify that so is is that something
that uh I guess other speakers will be
able to address or is that something
that we' have to have an amendment for
thank you for the observation
representative so um my understanding is
that the special adapted housing or
special home adapt adaptation Grant is
obtained through the Veterans
Administration so um that's my comment
there speaks to the use of the word by
however I can't sitting here right now
answer your question I know that the
bill that is in front of you speaks
specifically to the S sh
grants so that would have to be a
conversation as to
yeah are these technical questions going
forward or um like representative
suggested maybe we if they're technical
questions can they be given to one of
our upcoming or is it specific go ahead
representative Brown so this is just a
another piece of the language down in
line 16 I I happen to know several
people that are 100% disabled by the
veterans but they are unemployed and
this talks about unemploy employability
so is that something that can be
addressed a lot of these people have
mental health issues where they can work
but uh and so they're still employable
but they have 100% disability would this
count for
that so thank you for the question
representative to be clear you you're
you're speaking to 100% permanently and
totally disabled we which does which
does indicate
unemployability that part of the text is
is not changed so it's not relative
thank you I think that's the proper
answer uh keep in mind represent all
Representatives on the table that only
the Bold is the actual change is
anything else that's there is generally
existing representative almost yes
represent thank you
um going to back to kind of the purpose
of this instead of the the wording that
you chose
um the goal of this legislation is not
necessarily to change the um people that
are
currently
um um qualifying but to make it um the
language more uh transparent to who does
and does not qualify is that your
understanding thank you representative
that is that is correct the intent of
this bill is to Simply clarify the
statute thank you further questions
seeing none thank you representative
power next we'll call uh Jim
misho
thank you Mr chair
uh my name is Jim misho I am the chief
assessor for the town of Hudson uh I'm
neither for nor against this bill I just
point out some administrative aspects to
it and um just my understanding of how
the law currently reads versus um The
Proposal we have two of these in Hudson
two properties that are receiving the
100% exemption as a point of reference
according to dr's online data there's a
total of $25.6 million in Exempted value
currently under of this total exemption
RSA uh the dr's online data currently
doesn't show the actual count of
residences Exempted by my recollection
is it is definitely less than a 100 in
the whole
state going to lines on the
bill let's see 12 through
13 the part that says the person or
person surviving spouse and then bold
who does not remarry that is um that's
addressed all already in RSA
72 um it says the term surviving spouse
shall not include a surviving spouse
that has remarried but if and this is
for all of 72 tax
credits um shall not include a surviving
spouse that is remarried but if the
surviving spouse is later divorced his
or her status as surviving spouse of a
veteran is
regained so that's the way the law
currently reads as it applies to this
exemption The Proposal is if they
remarry it doesn't matter if if they get
divorced they're not going to get it
back so that's a change from how it
currently is um the body of my written
testimony um goes to how the law is
currently
[Music]
written versus The Proposal that I'm
concerned that we're going to have folks
that are currently getting it that will
have their exemption
removed and I'm not sure if that was the
intention this really doesn't go to the
the part about clarifying this goes to
the definition under
2150 so it's very wordy in my written
testimony and I will get absolutely
tongue tied up here trying to address it
all because it's more of a give and take
discussion um and uh sometimes it's
better for a session other than a public
hearing so I'm going to finish up my
testimony with that um I just I do have
concerns of folks that might be losing
this about the retroactivity of this um
and definitely with the definition what
we're he hearing is that communities are
not applying this correctly well if this
corrects it then there's going to be
people losing it I would imagine every
Community would have to revisit of those
you know relatively small number under
100 but they still have that
responsibility to revisit it so I'm not
saying that's a reason to be against
this I'm just saying something's to be
aware thank you thank
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question um in line five um the current
law states that um if someone owns a
specially adapted Homestead which has
been acquired with the assistance of
veterans and
administration
um that seems very broad um as far as I
thought that um there is some loan
programs um and not necessarily just
these um special adapted housing and
special home adaption grants um
that um
currently uh the assistance of Veterans
Administration is very Broad and any if
if someone used any money from the
Veterans Administration essentially to
purchase this home and and adapted it
themselves let's say that would
currently under the law be
um uh they would be eligible for this
paragraph but under the new
uh language it would have to be they
have to get this money specifically from
these Grant programs um do you see is
that the where some of your concern is
as far as like people not being um
eligible anymore that were previously
eligible thank you for the question
representative thank you my my con my
concern is that we're redefining what
veteran is for purposes of the
application of this statute we're taking
2150 and rep replacing how it's
currently administered and so there's
different classes of discharges that are
addressed in the body of my written
testimony so it's not the part about the
grant it's a part about the definition
of the veteran I actually think that the
language clarifying using those specific
words from the federal government from
the uh VA are helpful um we just went
through one of these and we we were
looking and did get copies of the
specially adapted Grant um document so
um we also benefit from um what's what I
call the Belmont decision which was a
decision that went up to Supreme Court
um that clarified um how the certain
disabled veteran exemption is to be
applied um and that's the most recent
and probably only most recent uh case
that further comments
questions see none thank you for your
test oh sorry representative Gilman
sorry I came in late thank you Mr chair
I have a question that may be answered
in the um uh handouts that we just
received um where did it go on line 11
it uh talks about a home that has
received the sah or sha Grant um owns
the home and especially adopted and has
been acquired using proceeds from the
sale of such a home would you interpret
that as someone who has an adapted home
sells it and the next person gets
exemption so someone that's not a
certain disabled veteran acquiring the
home no they would have to meet that
criteria if if a second disabled veteran
buys a home
home um that has been adapted using the
proceeds from one either the grant
program
or I don't I don't see it that
you okay thank you thank you very much
uh the next individual and unless
there's anybody else in here who hasn't
signed a card I only have one more and
y uh good morning chairman uh members of
the municipal County committee for the
record my name is William Gad spel g d
Au and I'm the director for the New
Hampshire division of veteran
services uh as stated by the prime
sponsor for the bill um we're hoping to
clarify the language for the eligibility
ility for certain disabled veterans to
be exempt from property tax taxation on
a household that was adapted through a
Veterans Administration special adaptive
housing or special home adaptation Grant
or that was acquired through use of pro
proceeds from the sale of such a sah or
SHA home the department of military
Affairs and veteran services requested
this Legislative Assistant to clean up
the language in RSA 72 36a uh the rsa's
current language is not specific enough
to establish solit criteria for for
those who might qualify under this RSA
and in many cases has been too open to
interpretation by the assessors that
would be uh that would approve the 7236
alpha or by the veterans who seek tax
exemption under this RSA this language
removes doubt as to who qualifies for
the exemption as it establishes that a
veteran must be so disabled that the VA
has deemed them 100% permanently totally
and determined that they further qualify
for extensive home ad adaptations
through the VA special adaptive housing
sah or S ha Grant uh or a VA special uh
housing
adaptation uh for a veteran to qualify
for the
$177,000 grant
approximately uh that's the amount for
fiscal year 2024 they have to get approv
the grant uh and the VA will look at
that they only do 120 applications
annually a veteran must have one or more
of the following qualifying service
connected disability these are not just
disabilities they have to be service
connected disabilities in in order to
qualify for the va's sah or sh Grant uh
the loss or the loss of use of more than
one limb uh the loss or loss of use of a
lower leg alone with the residuals
lasting effects of an organic disease or
injury blindness in both eyes certain
severe burns the loss or the loss of use
of one of the lower extremities after
September 11th 2001
uh which makes it so uh that the
individual can't balance or walk without
the help of braces crutches canes or
wheelchairs uh for a veteran to qualify
for the special ha Grant the special
home adaptation which is
23444 uh he or she must have one of the
following service connected conditions
the loss or the loss of use of both
hands certain severe burns certain
respiratory or breathing injuries and
before I actually conclude my test
I I want to kind of bring up a couple
examples of the reason why I brought
this forward or asked to have this
language clarify I've had veterans
believe me when I get when it comes to
veteran tax CR credits I get all the
questions and when they contact me I got
a lot of people who interpret laws
differently and the way the law is
currently written I've got individual
who will call me up and they'll say well
I'm 100% permanent total and I got my
home through a VA home loan so I qualify
for an exemption well there's already a
property tax credit for somebody who's
permanently totally disabled that's up
to a $4,000 tax credit so I have to
explain to them you think the threshold
between a $44,000 tax credit is a and a
complete exemption is the approval of a
VA home loan which is obviously I don't
believe the intent of this law when it
was written was for it was for veterans
who not only permanently totally
disabled but they're so disabled that
they require special adaptations to
their home which the VA pays for in a
special housing adaptation or special
adaptive housing Grant additionally I
had a veteran call me up and said well I
have a I have a adapted my home I paid
for a $10,000 walk-in tub so I should
qualify for this grant I said did you
get that money from the VA no I did it
myself I said well that's a great
investment that you made a 10,000 tub
for tax exemption for the rest of your
life so You' have I I told the veteran
my suggestion was to go back to the VA
and ask for special adaptive housing or
sah grant for that home a couple
questions were asked here about
permanent total and
unemployability so permanent total it's
important to understand that a per
perent total disability does not
automatically mean that the veteran is
on crutches or they're in a wheelchair I
am 90% service connected many people
look at me would have no idea that I'm
90% service connected and I'm currently
in the process to get my evaluation
raised to 100% permanent total so 100%
permanent total does not mean the
veteran cannot walk cannot do things
does not mean they're unemployable 100%
permanent total just means that the
totality of their disabilities the VA
believes are permanent and will never
change so that's why they rate them the
100% permanent total in addition
unemployability is not something the VA
grants it's something that a veteran
applies for and has to be approved by
the VA so the VA just doesn't really
nearly Grant people unemployability it's
veterans who have disabilities that are
so severe that they request from the VA
to get
unemployability because they can no
longer work they're telling the VA they
can no longer work so that's really the
difference between a permanent total and
an unemployability you can be 100%
permanent total and not be
unemployable right or you can be both
you can be permanent total and the VA
considers you
unemployable so I just want to make
those distinctions and I open myself up
for any
questions okay thank you for your
testimony representative
Kella thank you thank you for taking the
question um so kind of going back to my
previous question um the it seems like
their concern was about the definition
of veteran and your concern more is
about the um the vagueness of acquired
with the assistance of veterans uh
Administration kind of like I alluded to
earlier um do you see any concern about
the change in the definition of
veteran well I I I don't believe this
does change the definition of veteran
again this specifically is looking or
should not be changing the definition of
veteran uh it should be looking to
stipulate that in order to qualify for
this tax exemption you not only have to
be 100% permanent total but you also
have to have an approved sah or sha
grant that literally is the basis for
what I'm asking for in this is just to
make that so that nobody's asking that
question well you know I have this going
on or somebody asked if I had it my
house adapted for me through May through
another another organization that did it
for me
that's not the same thing as a SE that
other organization May adapt your home
for you but maybe not because you have a
service connected disability you have a
disability right so not all disabilities
that veterans have or service related
this specifically is
service these these grants or for
specific service connected
disabilities represent Mill thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question I
heard you mention a date um like
September 11th
so I just you needed some clarification
you can only qualify for this particular
thing if your service connected injury
happened after September 11th and you
qualify for these grants so that's so
that's VA because that's all that stuff
down there is all that part of it is VA
criteria so they do have spe specific
criteria for and that's only in this
specific area right so the loss or loss
of use of one low one lower extremity
Fort Lake after September 11 2001 so
that's the VA stipulation I don't know
why the VA stipulated
that yeah I will tell you that the VA
does have a a 2001 September 11 2001
stipulation for a lot of their rules I
don't know why they have
that and I'm not the
VA thank you further
questions just one really really really
quick one um is is it my understanding
or that your intention for this language
change is merely to clarify it doesn't
change who qualifies who doesn't qualify
strictly to
clarify that that is correct it it it
literally that's does not change
eligibility it just helps clarify the
language U and as the the assessor Mr
mad mentioned there might be some people
that will absolutely potentially lose
out on their tax exemption if the town
assessed or looked at it or did not
understand or did not the the the
interpretations were were different so
there might be people that lose out on
this benefit okay thank you represent
David so therefore it would hinge on
qualific on
eligibility it's not simply a language
change it's a substantive
change is that a question that's that's
a question for the gentleman
testify in your opinion does that
language even though it might affect
eligibility for some veterans already
receiving this credit is it just
clarifying language even though that
might
happen I'm yes I believe it is right so
I are there people out there that may
have gotten this benefit and maybe
weren't authorized it or shouldn't have
gotten it because they lawyered the law
sure I I believe that those individuals
if it didn't apply if if they
used their own their own own
interpretation to try to get a benefit
that they didn't wasn't wasn't really
designed for
them again at the end of the day for me
it's about intent of the law and it's
hard to read intent in the language but
I believe the intent was to say if you
are a veteran who is so disabled and
you're permanently total and you're so
disabled that you require assistance
through the VA to to live in your own
home I believe those are the individuals
that this was designed for there are
obviously those individuals who have
used
their own language their own
interpretation of the law and maybe an
assessor didn't push back or they were
granted it uh it definitely wasn't to me
designed for somebody who's 100%
permanent total and qualifies for a VA
example okay seeing no questions thank
you for your testimony I have no more
people I'm sorry I didn't see it no you
you can continue out or um it sounds
like you were actually about to address
what I was going to ask about anyways so
address the what or the blue sheet
signin it was yeah okay so yeah uh there
were just four people on the sign in on
the blue sheet um couple neutrals and
two
four and a couple of those individuals
actually spoke so there anyone else
here was there any is there anybody else
here wishing to
testify I see none I have no more pink
cards thank you close the hearing on
1154 I apologize to those
individuals waiting to testify on under
bills the chairman of this committee has
once again failed greatly to estimate
the timing on some of these bills I
apologize for that so we're going to go
right into hb10 55 Mr chairman can you
sorry
Mr
chairman as a member of the committee
this this last bill and a couple of the
other bills that we're hearing
today there's a real possibility that I
could benefit from those personally
what restriction do I have in
participating and voting since I it's a
very real
possibility uh that I could
benefit uh is there a restriction as far
as participating in this I don't believe
there's any part uh restrictions on
participating here once we get into it
maybe the exact session or on the house
floor possibility um I'll have to look
into the
specifics of that because I'm not I know
you do have the ability to sign an
Ethics related document that says you
know I am or am not going to vote on
this because but uh I don't know this
not an expert on
that but right here in the hearing you
you
morning Mr chairman thank you for uh the
Indulgence to me finishing up my notes
in the previous hearing okay now we'll
open up the hearing on HB 1055 I not
realized why you needed time
representative McDonald now I know okay
go ahead uh thank you very much this uh
bill came to my attention uh last
beginning of last year I guess it was I
don't know if your community we have
small school houses that have been
around for like a 150 years or churches
that just sit out on the side of the
road on a field they have no power no
running water they're just things that
part of our community that we've had for
so many years uh a couple of the the
churches ran into some problems trying
to get their documents all together to
prove that they were
nonprofits and this will address this
issue
uh gives them some extra opportunity to
get to try to get the Dos together so
they can get the
uh the waiver on the taxes um I spoke
and worked with the municipal
Association and also worked with uh my
town assessor um who's also here
hopefully and if you could direct your
questions at him as far as how it's
going to affect your your community
up thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
Todd members of the committee my name's
Todd Haywood I am a contract assessor I
have 10 communities that I do assessing
for and wolfboro happens to be one of
them and it this bill seems to be more
of a housekeeping item where you're
going to
afford a similar um flexibility to the
municipalities to accept uh late
documentation and still Grant the
exemption for some of these charities in
particular um where the way it stands
now is if the Charities don't submit
their
financials by before June 1st if it's
received on June 1st they shall be
denied the exemption we we were hoping
that we could have flexibility to accept
those necessary paperwork later but
before the setting of the tax rate so
this is in my opinion a housekeeping
issue and um and I think that's it and
and can I add on 7223 c yeah you like to
so so representative McDonald did speak
about 7223 C which Roman numeral 2 which
um allows the assessors selectman to
request documentation such as the
Articles of Incorporation or certificate
of good standing or anything else we
think is is relevant to granting the
exemption right now it says if you if
you're requested you shall respond
within 30 days or you shall be denied
we're hoping that we can have some
flexibility on that regard as well what
happened in one of my communities
was we requested the
information we got the the information
received the information but it wasn't
within 30 days so we had to assess them
a year's taxes for these churches and
Charities and we're just we're just
hoping that the legislature will see fit
to allow some flexibility by the
selectman or whomever the local
is representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I've been out of
the nonprofit business for about 15
years but isn't it form 990
informational filing that is due uh to
the IRS by these
Charities so that that is a requirement
by the IRS but it doesn't have to be a
form 990 that's provided to the
municipality similar information is what
we're looking for but it doesn't have to
be the 990 if I could follow up do you
know when the form 990 is due well it's
due in November at the latest which is
past our tax rate setting got it thank
you representative Elward small
technical issue when you request a
followup requests through the chair
please not a big deal thank you uh
representative
stav thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um planning board
parlament the phras is mistake or
Misfortune which is mentioned in line
nine of the bill is um conflated to the
words um good
cause uh which has legal standing that
phrase does and I'm wondering
if I wondered if you had considered
Misfortune either either doesn't matter
as far as I'm concerned as long as
there's some flexibility but you bring
up a good point accident mistake or
Misfortune isn't defined and it would be
helpful if it were for someone like me
it would be helpful if it were defined
because you could as you've heard
earlier you could you could interpret
anything any way you like if it behooves
you represent representative
yala thank you thank you for taking the
question
um there are a bunch of
exemptions um that need to be requested
annually
um does any other
exemptions um that you're aware
of allow for this
flexibility um by the
select board or the governing body to uh
uh wave those deadlines so the per the
personal exemptions are permanent which
your veterans elderly Etc and those are
um those do allow for accident mistake
or Misfortune which is inde defined but
you can take it
later the the institutional exemptions
is what we're we're talking about the
Charities the schools and the churches
are annual so they have to apply every
year and
their application allows it's in the law
that allows for them to be uh if there's
an accident mistake or Misfortune to
prevented them from filing timely the
selectman can accept it but it doesn't
allow for the financials to be accepted
late and that's that's what we're that's
what we're hoping for so we're actually
looking to bring this into the
continuity of all the other exemption
laws at least that's how I see it
anyways thank
power thank you Mr chairman so as I look
at the the Bold language which is the
amended language to be included I notice
on lines nine and 10 it says may
receive
so that leaves the option up to the
officials to either receive the
information or not to receive the
information was that the intent here
it's still up to the discretion I think
so I think the discretion is what we're
looking for for the
municipality and you could correct me if
agree further
questions I have one question
um in addition to the accident mistake
Misfortune language um at what point
what is the earliest date that a
nonprofit could
file um their exemption request
the day after the tax bill is issued it
it the filing period is the final notice
of tax until April 15 but you have to
1st
okay thank you further questions
represent
majori thank you and thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that in my town we just had this issue
and the select board had no idea how to
comport with the law we had to make it
up as we were going along and we just
said get it to us and let's talk the
next meeting thank you I I believe
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr
chairman next we'll call uh
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire I represent the town of Epsom um
I'm just here to request that you do not
exec House Bill
1055 until you've had a public hearing
for House Bill
1317 which
um affects exactly the same paragraph
for exactly the same reason but in a
different way so you know you may not be
aware of it but House Bill 1317 is
coming uh and it's it's it's very
similar to this bill so so please don't
EXA this bill until some later time and
that's
all excellent testimony representative
Maguire questions seeing none thank you
very
much oh
okay uh next up
uh Alysa margolus did I get that right
close
molia I don't can't make out your
L thank you Mr chairman for the record
my name is Alyssa margolin and I'm here
today speaking on behalf of the New
Hampshire Center for nonprofits we're
the Statewide Association um that
supports the nonprofit sector in New
Hampshire as you know um the pandemic
taught us how integral nonprofits are in
all New Hampshire communities um and
many ways New Hampshire is a little
different than other states our
nonprofit sector is often providing
essential Services where government and
other states would be providing that we
have many nonprofits in New Hampshire um
often the number of them is
misunderstood because so many uh out of
state nonprofit are required to register
in order to fundraise here we have about
7,000 nonprofits they actually make up
onethird of New Hampshire's Workforce
and generate billions to the economy but
as you know in your communities
nonprofits are often very small and lack
administrative support most many grants
and government grants and philanthropy
limit the amount of overhead and limit
the amount of administrative support So
deadlines mistakes misfortunes accidents
do happen um and we appreciate the um
the prime sponsor's intent to enable
municipalities to allow for a little
flexibility in those cases um when a
nonprofit is uh owning a property and
using it for Mission related purposes
they benefit from a property tax
exemption and have to file this annual
filing um so that we hope that the
committee will consider uh enabling
municipalities to partner with these
essential nonprofits in their community
thank
you thank
you questions from the committee see
none thank you for your
testimony uh
misho thank you Mr chair Jim misho Chief
assessor in Hudson New Hampshire um I am
in favor of this bill I I believe that
um this I know that this language was
lifted from RSA 72 colon 33 i- a so this
language mirrors the accident mistake
Misfortune part that is available for
those personal exemptions and personal
credits um so this gives the Selectmen
that Authority that they don't currently
have if it comes in June second and it's
not postmarked too bad so sad um and I
don't think that that's that's the
proper way to deal with with this
exemption um we are though I think in
need of having a definition of what
accident mistakes Misfortune is and we
don't have that in law currently but we
do have it in rule um Dr administrative
rules rev 12
01.01 defines it but that's only in
regards to low and moderate the btla
also has administrative rule that
defines that but it's not in relation to
the statute so I'd like to pass this
definition over to repres representative
from Lichfield and um I think it would
be beneficial for the local Selectmen
when presented with this what is an
accident mistake Misfortune we have a
definition I don't know if we have case
law and that's the extent of my
testimony very good thank you that' be
appreciated if you gave them that uh
rule are there questions from the
committee I see none thank you very
much
uh is Nate here I don't see Nate
must be gone somewhere
else okay have uh was there anybody else
looking to testify on this bill seeing
none uh there are no signings on the
blue sheet so with that we'll go ahead
1055 all
right
um representative Moffett was here
here he's in the hallway see if I he's
in the hallway somebody send him in
you we are going to open up the hearing
now on HB 1258 relative to a waiver from
property taxes for disabled veterans Mr
chair I'm I'm sorry to interrupt but the
clerk still isn't here can you give me
just a second to catch up with whatever
he we're going to wait a second all
right Assuming he's going to come back
and take over so all right we'll take a
to
the langu came
up I'm seeing a permanent $4,000 cap you
probably
okay until uh our clerk clerk gets back
represented majority will perform that
action so we will now go ahead and open
up the hearing on HB 1258 relative to
proper ta uh waiver of property taets
for disabled
veterans representative Moffet I assume
you are
the thank you Mr chair I am the prime
sponsor for this measure I am here happy
to be here uh very short as you can see
very very short uh and hopefully sweet
for the record my name is uh
representative Mike Moffett I represent
marac District 4 the lovely towns of
Canterbury and Lowden uh the simple
intent of this measure is to provide
enabling enabling legislation to
municipalities
so that if if locally there is is
sentiment to exercise the uh the totally
disabled veteran tax option then uh said
municipality could offer uh a tax credit
of up to 100% of the local property tax
uh again this is enabling it would be up
to the locality up to the
municipality um currently
RSA uh and you see the number there uh
72 colon 27 uh does allow for a tax
break of up to
$4,000 that's what's currently in
statute what this would do would be to
increase that from $44,000 to
100% uh again at the discretion of the
uh
municipality uh now the total disability
would have to be service related and I
know there's some complicated
potentially complicated definitions in
terms of uh what constitutes
100% uh of a
disability but the again the intent here
uh if you can just imagine or or think
of uh Springfield I guess there is a
Springfield but
um uh any Town New Hampshire uh John
Smith is a veteran uh who was uh
grievously injured in in combat 100%
disabled so he lives in any any town and
he and his wife or whatever uh his
circumstances are such that he has an
$88,000 tax
bill uh he could get under current
statute $4,000 in relief uh but he has
an $88,000 bill and his circumstances
are set that he can't pay the property
taxes so he would need to move or sell
his sell his house and the the good
folks in any Town New Hampshire don't
want to see John have to give up his
home or leave so that's the intent of
this he would uh John Smith would be
able to uh request or petition or or
someone could ask for him for for up to
the 100% option and if the if his n his
uh fellow uh any Town residents wanted
to offer that to him then they could if
this were to move forward so that's the
uh the long and the short of it again
enabling legislation with uh local
control over its use or employment or or
not and that is what I have and I'd be
happy to try to take any questions if
any does anybody have any
questions for representative M uh
mofet representative
power thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question in line two you
reference
total I sorry that part of the statute
question I'm sorry
representative you I think you can in in
regards to this I don't see why you
can't it's not being changed doesn't
mean you can no don't want to okay it's
fine I'm not sure what the question was
but it sounds like it it was answered
thank you Mr
she's retracting her question any other
questions from the committee I just have
one uh represent mofit um do you know
approximately with this change how many
individuals in New Hampshire would
qualify for this roughly uh that's a
good question Mr chair and I I don't
have a I do not even have a ballpark
figure uh there are some folks here from
U esvac uh State veterans advisory
committee who who uh very well may have
some information in the area but I I
could I would not venture to guess at
this time I am getting a nod from
somebody in the back of the room saying
he has that
um so I will wait to hear from that
individual any further questions
represent
power thank you for taking my question
so I was just curious why this um bill
doesn't have a fiscal note because
fiscal
notes other fiscal notes that I've seen
um speak to State County and town I'm
just wondering why we don't have that
note well a lot of uh thank you
represent of power for the question uh I
I see FN notes all the time on measures
you notti this says local so I I think
the FNS that that the folks here in
conquer uh research have to do with with
State monies and this would be local U
so the estimate of uh potential cost
locally uh goes to I think to the the
chair the chair's question about how
many folks there are out there who may
benefit from this around the state which
I'm not sure of but you didn't the case
somebody behind me was giving you some
uh some good vibes on that so
uh if does that kind of answer your
question representative I it's a local
FN thank you further questions
representative y
Kella thank you thank you for taking the
question um
when someone puts um something on the
warrant article or trying to pass this
um they have to indicate the tax impact
of of the
measure and um they can do that with a
specific dollar amount however with
100% there's no known amount that the uh
that the voters would be
granting uh a waiver for um have you
thought about that um issue as far as um
how um to explain that to the voters
essentially of how much money that
they're shifting from one person's
pocket to another's sure thank you rep y
it's a great question uh in terms of
Warren articles uh if a municipality if
someone in a municipality get the
requisite uh signatures to get a Warren
article placed then they would they
could word it in different ways they
could uh have a a figure of in the
Warren article of making this tax
benefit available uh for an amount up to
x amount of dollars uh because I I think
I get your point it without that uh it
could be an open-ended uh unfunded
Mandate of sorts if I'm if I'm tracking
you so were this to be go to a uh Warren
article the Crafters or the writers of
the article would have to uh decide if
they wanted to
make this available to like I said up up
to a certain point that's how I would
answer that in terms of applying this to
article represent P thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question representative
um to the the point that the member just
made with regards to you have a fix fix
dollar amount on the low end and then it
says up to 100% of the property tax well
clearly different individuals have
different tax bills sure so um it's not
clear to me how something like this
would be
administered yeah thank you for the for
the question and again I I kind of
touched on this and that's a very good
question um this goes back to this being
enabling legislation so a town to if
someone in a town wanted to submit a
warrant article with the requisite
signatures to uh create this
benefit uh presumably within the town
they would have done some some local
Homer every Town's different uh some
towns uh may have no one that would
qualify and some Town larger towns may
have several so to try to answer that
question that it would depend on the
municipality um and doing some local
research and homework in terms of how
many dis how many 100% disabled veterans
live in any Town New Hampshire uh and if
and and that is information that could
be uh
researched and if there are none then
there are none or if there are
potentially uh 10 or 12 then you know
those numbers could be extrapolated as
to the potential liability if the town
available representative Guthrie yes if
I can I think you're correct that that
that number can be extrapolated uh and
you come up with the number very easily
you know how much you're paying the
veterans benefit at the present time and
you you take
100% uh it's just a mathematical thing
but I also if I could uh suggest to you
that the article doesn't have have to
have any money in it the article could
should just be clearcut and say 10 say
100% there's no need to put the money in
there you might have a inquiry as to
what it is but I suggest that the that
it is a it would be a an article with no
funds
attached thank you gu sure I think every
Town's different and we're a town to a
town now can can try to put this in for
the benefit of up to 4,000 if if they
wanted to put an article in you I think
you're correct they they don't have to U
specifically list the potential
liability they they could uh again that
goes back to the local uh uh submitters
of a potential warrant article but uh
sure I
the real question is whether or not real
question is whether or not it would pass
thank you for your comments and you have
you and further questions representative
yella then
represent thank you um for taking
another question
um it seems
like
$71 um and why not just essentially
eliminate any guidance from the state as
far as what um the tax amount could be
what what is your
um Logic for for that thank you for the
question representative the the $71
figure is already in statute uh how that
was placed there or when that was placed
there I I couldn't tell you but that's
what's there now uh the current statute
uh makes this benefit available uh for
taxes from 701 up to 4,000 so the 7001
figure is there I'm not sure how that
originally uh became law but that is is
what's law now I I couldn't tell you
exactly how or when that uh OS probably
could but uh where the 701 came from I
exactly repr BR thanks for taking my
question
so we've heard a lot of other testimony
today on other bills that basically
relate directly to the person's primary
resid I don't see anything in regard to
that
here thank you uh represent Brown so
your question has to do with primary
residents as opposed to uh a second home
is that well basically basically any
other home or any other property I mean
I would think what we're looking at here
is trying to make sure that a disabled
veteran
has the ability to not pay taxes on his
residents yeah thank you represent good
question that's why we have these
hearings so if if any town uh is on Lake
wiip and the in the home that uh
that John Smith the disabled veteran has
is on uh Lake winaki and it's a very
expensive of home that's kind of maybe
the your thought process would would set
a place it be uh would it be appropriate
for such a situation for the veteran to
be able to get this 100% benefit which
if any town was in a rich Community it
could be a $20,000 break uh right so
part of my answer is that uh of course
the committee uh owns the bill after the
hearing in if if that piece if there's
some wording that could address that
concern that's possible that's that's
actually a good question uh my thinking
is that if if any town is a rich
Community the the folks who live in any
town uh that you know they know their
town and they know their circumstances
and finances and dyn Dynamics and and
the folks who live there so uh I hadn't
thought of that but but that's something
perhaps a Comm might want to
uh address in some
fashion thank you thank
you further
questions seeing none I have one
representative um is it your
understanding that by changing the 100%
figure would that require a warrant
article the question is would going to
100% versus 4,000 require a warrant
article
uh I would go to the good folks in
Municipal and County the experts on that
and ask some some folks on that
committee about that I uh it's great
question and and I I don't have a ready
answer for that but that's a great
question I asked it only because I do
know the answer
but I
wanted this will be for the executive
session or as we proceed I don't need to
talk about it right now okay further
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
m uh next up we have uh William Gad
yes thank you again committee members uh
my name is William Gro a director for
the New Hampshire division of veteran
services uh the uh Department of
military's Affairs and Veteran servic
were neutral on this bill I I just
wanted to come up and bring some
information kind of along the lines I've
already spoken about uh while
representative maford is absolutely
correct this would apply to John Smith
who may have been wounded in war and
came back here is now 100% permanent
total but this would also apply to John
Smith's brother Mike who is also 100%
permanent total and makes $200,000 a
year so if you grant this to John you
would be granting this to every in
within that City every other veteran
who's 100% permanent total but not have
disabilities that are significant enough
to keep them from being employed so i'
out representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so I will ask
the question that I was going to ask of
the Prime sponsor because you brought it
up in your comments so you were
referring to permanent and total
disability where the text
of this bill and it's not being modified
it's in current statute only refers to
service connected total disability there
there's a difference there's no
difference no difference it's the same
it's just a it's just a the way it's
said some people say total and permanent
some people say permanent in total it's
the same thing thank
you representative
yella thank you um thank you for taking
the the question um
this uh potential change
essentially
uh could make the bill that
you just talked about
essentially um moot because all of the
people that would be granted 100% under
that law would be could be granted 100%
under this law um do you see that that
um is is uh a
concern
uh or or do you think that uh that there
is some value in having both well
because this legislation that just
proposed was enabling I don't think it
moots ours because there are maybe a
town out there that wouldn't put this
one forward but still would be able to
Grant and take SE take care of somebody
who's 100% perent total and as have
those grants
uh through the through the VA so I don't
necessarily think it moots our bill uh
it would moot our bill if this was being
presented as a law that every city was
going to adopt and I think this that's
way further questions seeing none thank
you very much for your
testimony last pink card I have on this
so if anybody else was planning to speak
make sure you fill out a pink card last
one Jim
mishell
um one comment for Mr misho and
everybody here it really helps if you do
have written testimony to get that to
the committee in advance that way we can
a lot of times it's very helpful to see
it in advance but absolutely you can
always turn it in at the meeting thank
you point taken thank you Mr chair Jim
Mish show the town assessor and Hudson
uh I'm neither for nor against this bill
I just look at some administrative
aspects um as a point of reference
according to dr's online data for 2022
property tax year there were
3,619 service connected total disability
tax credits for tax year 2022 which
amounted to about $8.4 million and tax
dollars credited as opposed to
exemptions before you go on what would
the number again um the total number of
3,619 and these are tax credits as
opposed to exemptions right so this is
this is dollars that gets shifted right
so it's Revenue neutral in the community
you grant an exemption you grant a
credit it just kind of lowers it plays
into the tax rate uh the community gets
no less money for the ex credits and
exemptions granted so this works the
same way um in 2022 um the median was
$1,400 the median tax credit 73
communities are at the minimum of 701 41
communities are at the current maximum
of 4,000 and the rest of are in
between I do raise the following concern
and and this is the first uh percentage
based tax credit tax exemption bill I
think this committee has gotten this
year but consistent with prior years and
an has testified I have testified
percentage-based exemptions and tax
credits do not work within the property
tax administration
um process that we have in New Hampshire
we have to know the
number so the chicken or the egg right
the 100% of what 100% of the tax bill we
don't know what the tax bill is so we
already have our tax rate but we need to
the amount of the credit or the
exemption before we set the tax rate we
have to put it on the ms1 so uh a clean
change to this is change the $4,000
number you know these clean numbers work
percentages just are not not able to be
administered flat out it no different
this year than it was in Prior years um
and I gave an example in my T in my
written testimony I'm not going to dive
into it um but if you look back in any
of your bills from prior Years you'll
see the same kind of written and verbal
testimony percentages this don't work
that's it thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you for your representative
Brown thank you for taking my question
just a quick question I don't know
whether it was you or someone else who
said it before basically that uh to make
sure we get the tax taxes straight that
we would use the previous year's tax for
that
individual as opposed to when we did an
exemption so you could use a previous
year's number instead of having to
figure out what the current rate was for
that exemption is that correct thank you
for the question representative um if
the legislation was change the proposal
was changed to state that
um it's possible to to do that um
because then you'd know the number right
you you'd know what the 100% is
um that might that might work not as
clean as a higher number clean make it
you know it's difficult to administer
these laws locally um not every
Community is the same and um I think a
clean approach is is is a better
approach um we already have 41
communities at the max maybe those 41 is
some of them want to go more than the
you further
questions see you none thank you for
your testimony having no more pink cards
uh blue sheet four people signed in
three neutral one
four and three of those spoke in front
of us so with that we'll go ahead and
close the hearing on hb1 1250 eight and
believe it or not we are back on time on
schedule uh we will start up again at
130 see everybody
it
here
okay we are past 130 we are going to
move on with our bills here next up
House Bill
1040 relative to including interest and
an Abad property tax refund at the rate
determined by the Department of Revenue
Administration representative leus you
floor thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um so if you request a uh an abatement
to your taxes in other words you think
your uh your assessment was too high you
still have to pay the full amount by the
due date and if your uh request for the
abatement succeeds then the town has to
has to return the money um and pay
interest on the time they kept it when
they shouldn't
have um little history on this back in
uh there was a bill SP 317 in
2022 um that was put in by Senator
Carson and that was generated at the
request of the U Board of Selectmen in
the town of Hudson I should have
mentioned I I represent Hudson and
Lichfield um because at that time
interest rates were you know almost zero
and the rate that the town was required
to pay was 6% and rightly the Boris
selectman thought that that was too high
so a bill was put in to reduce it to 4%
at that time I thought the correct thing
to do was to uh base it on some index so
that it would adjust as interest rates
adjust um but there wasn't time in the
process to come up with a good index and
amend the bill so the bill went through
so it's now 4% and and then you know
recently I when I was putting the bill
in I looked at interest rates you get
almost you could at that time get almost
6% just on a plain CD and so 4% wasn't
fair to somebody getting the abatement
back in 2022 6% wasn't fair to the town
and all the other
taxpayers um so the problem is with a
fixed rate most of the time it's going
to be wrong it's it's going to either
favor one side or the other which it
shouldn't so I had a couple discussions
with the uh State Treasurer to come up
with an index and we wanted something
that was readily
available um you know just to make it
easier for the uh you know the people
administrating this in the
municipalities and um we settled on was
uh uh the Department of Revenue
Administration has interest rates that
they charge businesses for overpayment
or underpayment of uh taxes like bet or
BPT um and that's based on some other
you know index I don't actually remember
which one offand but that's you know
always available on a on the State
website it's kind of official from the
state and so it's always
accessible um I had actually thought of
using a different index the liore but I
learned from the which is used to be the
most common one used for medium uh term
interest rates and the treasurer
fortunately uh told me that that one was
becoming disfavor was going away so
anyway what this bill would do is uh
base the interest rate on uh a number
that comes from the DSA and RSA 21j and
uh plus 2 percentage
points and that's that's basically what
the bill does and it'll solve this
problem we won't keep getting bills
late okay thank you for your testimony
do we have
questions from the
committee repres
Brown yeah just reading the bill I was
curious why did they add uh plus two
percentage points um I I took a look at
what the numbers have been um
historically so they had been um brought
up to 6% when interest rates were in a
certain range and they drop down to 4%
later probably they should be about 6%
now I at least when I put the bill in I
haven't looked at interest rates in a
little while uh and and doing this you
know looking at the numbers historically
that have been on uh the Dr website this
will yield um you know you would have
had the same interest rates we had
historically if this had been law at
that time and so it it it basically
follows what has been the interest rates
that have been used for this purpose in
the past and
um you know that seemed like the way to
go the the the thing to look at is that
if you look at RSA 21j 28 it's
complicated and uh um you know this one
refers to um a paragraph 2 which is some
other index you know minus
3% so this um and that's the one for
um overpayment of tax and I think the
way the Dr did it they're
uh I don't you know arguably not giving
businesses back as much as they should
should for over payment but mainly I did
this because it it follows what's been
done in the past and
so follow up Mr chairman follow I'm not
I'm not sure you understood specifically
what I was saying I was saying if the
Department of Revenue Services is is
coming up with an interest
rate I would think they would calculate
it based on what the current rate had
been and then they would assess that
payment to the town for
overpayment as opposed to PL thinking
like the plus 2% is a penalty or
something you understand what I'm saying
I do understand and um I mean if the
committee wants to change that of course
they're they're welcome to but I put it
that way so that it would follow what
that interest rate has been historically
for tax abatements I wasn't trying to
change you know that balance between the
town and and the or the other taxpayers
and the and the person getting the
abatement
representative sis thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question and why did you ever leave
Municipal and County
government
um explain to me why following up on
representative Brown's question tagging
on plus two percentage points at the end
of the the bill doesn't defeat the very
purpose that your bill is trying to
accomplish in other words aren't you
aren't you creating uh a an interest
rate that may not be in sync with the
Times by adding that 2% on um I would
argue no because the interest rate that
it's adjusting by the two percentage
Point does vary based on general
interest rate conditions um that's what
the drra rate is based on so it will
follow the interest rate and the times
and again I'm not going to try and read
dr's mind on why they decided to to do
it the way they did for
businesses but uh my goal was to you
know if if you look at when the rates
were adjusted in the past to have this
generate the same thing so that it would
have been you know when the legislature
decided to to set it to 6% this would
have made it six looking at the
Historical Dr numbers and when it went
to four this would have made it four and
so it should follow what the legislature
has done concerning uh batement interest
rates in the past I wasn't trying to
tilt the thing either you know more in
favor of the person in the abatement or
more in favor of the town or you could
look at it as all the other taxpayers
just to keep that balance the
same I was just trying to avoid the
committee having to deal with these
bills every couple of
years further
questions seeing none thank you very
you
okay I only have one pink card but I
don't
believe she is in the
room could you just representative Brown
could you just go in the hallway and see
if uh Katherine heck or Nate Grace is
there
please
oh there's n are you g to speak on uh
one
prepared uh well I may call you up after
it anyway but not right now we
um you have a card I I don't have it
you
it okay uh Jim
Michelle is
that yeah oh wait
minute yeah that's right that's right
it's
1034 oh all right uh Mr misho after you
finish
speaking uh I'll need you to fill out a
card for HB 1040 because I do not have
it this is
10:34 so if you could do that for me
after yes I will thank you Mr chair uh
for the record my name is Jim misho I am
the chief assessor for the town of
Hudson uh I'm here to testify in House
Bill
1040 um my written testimony gives a
little bit of history on how we are at
the 4% it was just two years ago that
the general court adopted the change
from 6 to 4% um this committee voted in
favor of it 19 to zero voted ought to
pass by the Full House in the consent
calendar that Bill had seven sponsors
one of the sponsors is my representative
leas in back of me from Hudson uh who's
now the sole sponsor of this bill um and
the the bill had zero opposition at the
public hearing process at the Senate
level um picking up on comments from
past bills from tax collectors when
there was an attempt in uh
2018 to tie abatement interest and or uh
underpayment right property tax payments
there was an attempt back then to tie it
to the state uh Dr interest rates so in
discussions with tax collectors
including Hudson's the bill as written
would require some software changes um
for each municipality and that could be
some additional cost right we're going
to be changing the rate of
interest um the Dr overpayment rate
changes annually on a calendar year
basis um so different interest rates
will be calculated for each year um the
software would be required to track and
then determine based on the length and
the number of years um um how much
interest is going to be charged for each
year currently it's one rate it's 4% um
this would require each year to be
separately calculated by the tax
collector um the uh prior legislation as
I said uh in House Bill 1673 in 2018
sought to align it the general court
rejected that um that's when they
changed the late payment interest rates
from 18 and 12 to 14 and 8 and then
subsequently the legislature passed the
change in AB batment add from 6% to 4%
so fixed non-fluctuating um year to year
the taxpayers know what the interest
rate is year to year the communities
know what the interest rate is um the
state determines its interest rate uh on
a calendar year basis but the towns
administer assessments and abatements on
a property tax year basis so if I apply
for an abatement in Hudson in 2023
November 15th and the abatement is
granted if this comes into pass I will
get one interest rate times my principal
but if the town doesn't process the
abatement till after January 1st it's
going to be a different interest rate So
within the same
Community ta different taxpayers will
have different interest rates that their
abatement is calculated off of we don't
have that currently currently we have it
it's the same from year to year but if
this passes it would change from year to
it would change within the tax year
within the same community and you know
if that's if that's fine then that then
that's that'll work right but people
will be treated differently
um and
lastly um the change in 22 didn't have
anything to do with the interest rates
the change in the abatement interests it
had to do with um catching up to the
change the legislature had made in the
under in the underpayment rates again
that went from 18 to 12 to 14 and 8 so
there was no no discussion back then in
the testimony and nothing I heard about
interest rates um further the states
mostly dealing with corporations and
businesses most of our communities are
dealing with individual
taxpayers um and having to explain
different interest rates to different
taxpayers and why they're treated
differently in the same year I'm not so
sure that that's going to be a fun uh
fun enjoyment for the tax collectors
testimony okay thank you um I didn't
catch it at the beginning if you said it
are you opposed neutral or against uh or
for my board of selectman's last
position on this was to ask Senator
Carson to introduce it at 4% so I'm
going to go with their last position on
this and I'll support their position
that that uh I'm in I'm in favor of the
current and not again and not not in
favor of this B you would be opposed I
would be opposed to this bill based upon
the selectman's past history are there
misho seeing none I have one and maybe
this will save n from having to come up
um and I mentioned with uh
representative
leus to me the rsas as they're written
now are a little bit confusing to me
3 it gives me some numbers and then it
says oh yeah and then apply these
28-2 is it your opinion that there would
be a much easier
way to have the rsa's read to avoid one
RSA sending you to another when you're
playing with all kinds kind of different
figures well yeah I'm in favor of How
It's currently written I mean that would
be my solution to it I but no that's not
what I'm I don't May well maybe you
understood what I said maybe I don't
asking couldn't you couldn't there be an
RSA written to incorporate two N3 into a
single RSA that's a little less
confusing or am I missing something not
speaking for the Department Revenue
because they can speak for themselves um
I I would say that there probably is a
probability you could write it where
they combined okay thank you I did have
one last thing I wanted to add um so
this the proposal says that the rate
determined by the
Dr okay which rate the prior year rate
the current year rate the calendar year
rate the property tax year rate so
that's that's probably just a little bit
of
clarity thank you
okay all right thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony again I did have a card from
Katherine Heck from all right I guess n
is
Gonna Fill in Mr chair I'm happy to come
up and uh do my best impression of
Catherine and you can all mock me later
very good um I'm I'm n gra the municipal
Association uh we do oppose the bill um
I believe uh Mr misho laid out uh most
of our points um to answer the chair's
question I do concur with the chair that
it is it is a bit confusing to write uh
uh to to reference um j28 uh 3 and then
in that ref reference two um I think it
it may be possible to clarify
that uh we we do as I mentioned we do
oppose the bill um and I think the last
point that Mr misho made was one of the
major points that we have based on the
notes that I have in front of me um
which is that we do need to have clarity
about what interest rate to apply when
um is there a cutof date at you know
December 31st or how how exactly does
that work it doesn't it appears not to
be clear based on the um individuals
that Katherine uh contacted about this
as to how that would function in
practice thank you there any
questions seeing none I have one yes
um would it be possible that the N
nhma yourself and maybe somebody else
maybe the current sponsor even though
the I know you don't like the direction
of where this is going and I'm not in
disagreement but maybe to take and use
this as a vehicle vcle
to make those two paragraphs clearer
would that be
possible we're always happy to work on
amendments Mr chair and I'm certainly
happy to volunteer my colleague
Katherine heck to do
so okay if you could relay that to miss
heck that would be great I will do so Mr
chair thank
you uh anybody else wishing to speak I
don't
um uh you yeah thank you n well set just
make sure you fill out a pink card for
us before you
leave you don't have to do it right now
leave good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is Keen
M Wong tax policy Council from new hsh
Department of Revenue Administration uh
I have not prepared any testimony for
this this bill um the Dr is does not
have a position on this bill but I heard
some questions relating to the
calculation of the uh interest rates on
from RSA 21 j28 and I I'll be glad to
provide some clarification on that so um
the rates on that's given in well the
calculation method essentially uh in 21
j28 um two uh Roman 2 refers to the
calculation for the underpayment of
taxes and then uh Roman Tree refers to
the calculation of overpayment of taxes
and this relates to all all the other
taxes that Dr administers and does not
apply to property
taxes and the uh the source of these um
the numbers are from the federal uh IRC
6621 Internal Revenue code of um 6 6621
A2 uh and that is provided from the um
legislation to say that that is where we
the Dr will obtain the the rates to
start the
calculation and then
to for the underpayment of taxes so the
Dr looks at the rates for uh September
of every year and calculates the rates
for the next calendar year as the
previous testimony that we calculate the
rates for on calendar year
basis and we issue the Dr issues those
rates uh through a technical information
release and it's published on our
website on on every on every
September the interest rates for
underpayment is using the Internal
Revenue code 6621
rate plus 2% that's based on the statute
and then to calculate the overpayment
the interest rate on the overpayment
it's using whatever rate that's already
been calculated so that plus 2% and then
minus 3% also that is uh as provided by
the statute and every year that rate
changes the current the current rate for
calendar year 2024 is 9% for
underpayment of taxes and 6% for
overpayment of taxes uh based on my
reading of HB
1040 what I I believe what it will do is
then um that 6% that's the overpayment
that's calculated by
Dr plus another
2% um and and oh yes and I think there
was some question about um how how the
uh interest rates are then being applied
so uh if that in an overpayment
situation um the let's say if uh the
currently the interest rate is 6% so the
it's going to be 6% and then calculated
on the number of days that the uh that
the Dr owes the money back to the
taxpayer uh for 2024 and if if it
relates back to the payment since 23
then it goes back to 4% for the 23 and
then 6% for the 24 so it's calculating
yab
um I'm not exactly I just just wanted to
clarify one of the statements that you
made because um I wrote down that your
the number that you gave was 9% for
overpayment and 6 for underpayment was
that backwards yes okay okay uh 9% is
for
underpayment and 6% is overpayment okay
lovely thank you that's for calendar
seeing none thank you for your testimony
before you leave today could you give me
a business card a pink card and you
don't have
one I I didn't bring one sorry I might
have I I'll look for it thank you thank
you forther
testimony seeing none we'll close the
okay we'll go ahead and open up the
hearing on 10 HP
1086 relative to public notice of zoning
board and adjustment hearings I see
representative Ren Zulu in the hot seat
yes sir is yours sir thank you very much
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
i' like to first off apologize for the
clown show that uh uh I last time I was
here relative to this bill uh that was
my ugly twin uh the
paternal paternal twin at any at any
rate first off uh I wish to emphasize
that this bill only affects the Zoning
Board of
adjustment uh hearings it does not
affect zoning ordinances or rezoning in
addition it does not affect a Butters
who by law must be notified by verified
mail it only repeat only affects
notification to the general
public right now the the public notice
for a zoning Board of adjustment hearing
can only be done by publication in a
newspaper of General circulation in the
area House Bill 1086 would allow the
publication of notice in the
municipality's internet website let's
compare the two processes in the
internet system which was being proposed
a municipal IAL clerk would type up and
format the notice and put the on the and
put it on the municipality's internet
website the clerk would build the
applicant for clerical costs in the
newspaper system the clerk would type up
the notice and mail either by stamp or
email the notice to the publisher the
publisher would prepare the copy print
and distribute the newspaper and send an
invoice to the clerk who would pay the
invoice and Bill the applicant for uh
both the clerical costs and the
publishing costs the newspaper system is
thus more costly to the applicant it is
also more costly to the
citizens because they have to buy the
newspaper imagine what would happen if
the clerk decided to charge all of each
of us for the calendar I don't think I'd
like it I don't know about you uh let's
look at the effectiveness in the
newspaper system the notice will be
printed in in one
issue was basically one day of the
newspaper is usually near classifi or
local
news a newspaper must be purchased it
also has a limited shelf life being
before it's discarded in the internet
system that's being proposed the notice
would be on the website from the time
it's posted at least 5 days before the
hearing the notice or the direct link to
the notice would be required to be
posted prominently on the website's
homepage in in addition the 5-day
requirements is a minimum so the notice
could be posted earlier and thus
displayed even longer and the internet
system is free repeat free to the
citizen they don't have to pay for
it they
don't excuse me free you don't have to
pay to get into the website is what I
meant times change people get their
information different differently excuse
me once it was only newspapers then
radio then television and now the
internet The Proposal allows this this
proposal allows notification to the be
the most people for the least expense
for the citizens the applicants and the
municipalities thank
you do you have any questions thank you
for your testimony uh representative
FR did I say that right by the way
perfect yes thank you thank you Mr
chairman I have two questions um the
first is I noticed that this only your
your bill only applies to zba notices
yes it does there there are other boards
land use boards and non-land use boards
that are also required to post notices
of hearing in the local newspaper why
are you not including them uh this is
only on the Zoning Board of adjustment
simple
because uh this is what was asked by the
uh uh by the zoning administrator at the
time uh the zone and it also the U far
as the other land use board it is my
understanding in another part of the
land use law that you are allowed or t
they the towns are allowed to notify uh
for the um for the planning
board uh in a different manner uh if I
is I think if I'm not mistaken uh uh it
I don't know the exact number but I can
find it for you if you'd like I I would
appreciate that information if you could
uh Supply it my second question if I may
Mr chair follow up yes go ahead
um have you done any studies on the law
of Revenue to the local newspapers as a
result of this proposed bill um we know
that local
papers have experienced a reduction in
advertising
overall and
um I'm
sorry I don't think that
applies um and I'm wondering what effect
if any the reduction in interview would
uh
result I I really don't know I really I
can uh I I expect that it might be a
reduction in in Revenue but uh we here
uh as
legislators should not want should not
try to play winner or
loser uh and we should uh you know we
should we should look for the best what
we can do for the for the citizens and
the taxpayers
uh I uh in addition U if I think my
friends from Lichfield will know the uh
you will recall the Hudson Lichfield
news which was a weekly that I don't
know if he real knows I doubt it but it
Incorporated uh I'm the R so I actually
did own for a while a uh a weekly
newspaper we used to publish the
uh uh the the uh
notifications one thing that we were we
were
free and none and also we went to every
home in Hudson and Lichfield by mail so
it but so it
was that was the the so we met the the
qualifications of being uh able to get
the in the public information to the
maximum number of of uh people of of
cost representative
awood thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative as I looked at this I was
concerned about absentee property owners
who might be able to prove that the
application could adversely or affect
their property and they would have to
check town website every 4 days let's
say I just learned that some websites
can you can
subscribe and it will push out notices
to people
subscribing um have you thought about
specifying that this
would only be applicable to town
websites that have that
ability um and make it instead of in lie
of in addition to uh the newspaper
advertising uh I have not uh considered
that but I'd be
welcome if the board if the uh committee
would like a a a uh uh an amendment to
that I would be uh happy to
participate thank
you represent Davis thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my
question several years ago this
committee passed a a bill vote voted in
favor of a bill to um to permit posting
of public meeting notices on
websites um I'm my concern and my
question for you has to do with
potential conflict between your bill and
RSA 91
A2 which states that if a public body
maintains an internet website it shall
either Post Its approved minutes or
notice of meeting in a reasonably
accessible location but it doesn't
insist that it do so so 91a 91a deals
with all meetings open to the
public and that's what that law state
which in my mind would supersede the
very narrow application just to
zba uh I don't necessarily
I that I cannot answer I don't I think
the 91a issue is simply uh is is is
Broad this is
specific uh the I know that uh the town
of Hudson uh there's another that there
is
another uh there's
another uh statue that allows the Zoning
Board of adjustment to uh to brought to
get to put out their notifications in a
different
manner uh and they do it actually
through the uh the Z to the publication
through the um uh uh through their rule
through their uh site plan regulations
so uh they have a system in that seems
to
you represent
Howard thank you Mr chairman and to the
representative's point 91a uses the word
meeting and a meeting is where the
public is allowed to speak there's some
opportunity a hearing a public hearing
is not the
same it's a convening of a board of a
public body but I think the reason this
is separate from 91a is because they
91a thank you I didn't ask a question
I'm
point further questions or points uh
questions from the committee no M
Representative kahill no you good all
right okay okay seeing no no more thank
you for your testimony we have one pink
card so far make sure if you intend to
speak on 1086 that you have a pink card
Grace thank you Mr chair this actually
is my bill n Grace the municipal
Association we do support this
legislation um the committee had a
number of questions uh I just say that I
agree with um the opening statements of
Representative Ren Zulo summarizing the
importance of this bill and how it would
affect municipalities applicants and
taxpayers um representative fra and
representative stavis had a couple of
related questions um about why there's
this specific notice as compared to um
you know why this only applies to cbas
versus you know uh the right to no law
91a um and part of what 91a says is that
there are other Provisions within the
statutes that have more specific notice
requirements one of those sections is
this section on uh notice of zba
hearings um and so it requires an
additional step um not only does that
publication have to occur uh in two
public places but it also has to be
published in a public
newspaper um so so there's this specific
requirement and what this bill would do
is allow publication on the website
instead of um instead of a newspaper and
I'll note this is a local option I
assume not all towns will take advantage
of this because there are five towns in
the state of New Hampshire that do not
have websites so obviously they would be
ineligible to qualify for publication on
their
website um uh representative fract also
uh
as part of his initial question there
about the
zba um RSA 675 colon7 Roman
1B um talks about public hearing notices
of zoning amendments those may be
published to the website um as
well um I believe there was a bill in
the past um that sought to change a
number of these more specific uh notice
requ requirements to allow uh internet
publication instead of in
newspapers um at that time the committee
had a number of concerns and wanted to
um go through those one by one um so
this is one of those um
and uh as far as representative award
asked a question about um subscriptions
to uh internet calendars I don't believe
there's currently anything in legis
ation requiring that be uh requiring
that occur if you have a website um but
I just want to point that out happy to
take any other questions the committee
may
have
questions I see none thank you thank you
for your
testimony was there anybody else wanting
to speak on this
bill seeing none we'll go ahead and
6 and there were no signings on the blue
okay we're at the pointed hour we'll go
ahead and open up the hearing on HB
1342 relative to the licensing of
electronic literacy materials by
libraries I show a rep filio as
the
sponsor
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the committee my name is
representative Shan filio and I have the
privilege of serving Chester district 7
which covers kean's W 2 and today I'm
going to introduce you to HB
1342 relative to the licensing of
electronic literary materials by
libraries this Bill seeks to prohibit
book publishers from Contracting ebook
licenses with libraries on terms grossly
different than those available to the
public it does so by making such
contracts that are different than those
available to the public unfair and
deceptive per the state's consumer
protection act and thus prosecutable by
our States Attorney General's office it
also creates a private right of action
for grieved libraries
ebooks have become a popular and
environmentally efficient means of book
lending but for libraries ebooks come
with a hefty price libraries which
purchase paper copy books retain some
privileges over those books due to the
first sale Doctrine in US copyright law
that is the possessor of a physical copy
of a book May lend that copy of will or
even sell that copy without further
intervention from the publisher the
relationship between the library and the
publisher completes at the sale of the
book but those paper copy privileges do
not translate to
ebooks rather ebooks are not governed by
copyright law they're governed by
contract law that is the license drafted
between the Lor and the lensey sets the
terms of how the ebook will be used used
and distributed the publisher can limit
the number of times an ebook can be
borrowed from a library or require that
the license for the ebook be repurchased
at set
intervals unfortunately the ebook
contract terms Publishers set for
libraries are often Draconian leaving
many institutions with a tough choice of
coughing up exorbitant fees repeatedly
or NAA offering ebooks at all
at a time when they're of increasing use
in interest for instance an ebook which
might cost a consumer
$9.99 often costs a library between $40
and
$110 for the Same Book for a limited
license frequently that license lasts
for either two years or a limited number
of checkouts regardless of whether the
patron actually reads the book or not
usually that's about 26 checkouts
at that point the library must either
relinquish the title back to the
publisher or again shell out the same
exorbitant
fee by contrast libraries frequently
attain paper copies the way that youur I
would do so through a local or online
vendor at the going rate while binding
for heavy use obviously increase the
cost of the book a bit those binding
fees are not the 4 100 to 1,00% increase
that libraries experience with ebooks
and that binding fee isn't paid every
two
years to analogize the present ebook
system is the equivalent of the
publisher entering a library and pulling
the hard copy book off a shelf under the
threat that if the library doesn't pay
for it again the publisher will seize
the already paid for title
now certainly if that happened the
public would be up in arms because the
public owns that
title and that bears
emphasizing we the taxpayers bear the
cost of this dysfunctional system we
bear the costs of paying the
Publishers estimates from the American
Library Association suggests public
libraries ebook costs have more than
doubled in the past 5 years and that
cost is still
increasing moreover Library ebook costs
now outstrip hard copy cost by a 5:1
margin and that is also
increasing our tax dollars are
increasingly spent to get
less ultimately this is a clash between
the profit driven model of private
publish
versus the public goods model of our
libraries which subsist on our tax
dollars when Publishers charge public
institutions
1,00% more and require that 1,00% be
paid
repeatedly we each foot the bill and we
have little to show for it aside the
same title over and over which is
available to others for far less now
admittedly as is often the case on these
bills there are counterarguments to the
bill otherwise we wouldn't even be here
today A frequently asserted argument by
Publishers is that authors bookstores
and the Publishers themselves couldn't
survive under the terms of this bill the
argument goes that if patrons could
simply borrow an ebook why would they
ever buy one the present practice
preserves costs and profits
but that's
ludicrous libraries have existed for
centuries and have always offered
patrons a choice purchase the book or
borrow it from the library and despite
that so-called competition book sellers
and authors have existed and will
continue to exist some people just
prefer the convenience of owning a title
or wish to own a beloved
book additionally in 2002 a federal
judge overturned a somewhat similar
Maryland law based on the federal
Supremacy power over copyright there is
a
substantial difference however between
the Maryland law and the proposed Bill
the difference between copyright and
contract namely the Maryland act sought
to dictate the manner in which book
sellers sell their Wares it dictated
quote
a publisher who offers to license an
electronic literary product arguably
that might be a topic within the federal
Constitution's copyright Clause since it
says if you sell books you shall do this
but the present Bill regulates quote
contracts between libraries and
Publishers a matter squarely within
State jurisdiction because contract law
law is a traditional State
concern the difference is subtle but
important one says if you sell books you
shall do this the other says if you
contract with libraries in this state
this specific practice is unfair and
deceptive it might be a slight
difference but the shift from copyright
to contract is important and as is so
often the case in law Details
Matter I ask you don't be deterred by
the Doomsday arguments you may encounter
our libraries in public deserve
Equitable terms to literary materials
and do not deserve to be an industry's
Cash
Cow though we might be in for a legal
battle from an industry eager to
preserve its profits at taxpayer expense
New Hampshire has always been first and
we will continue to lead the way I look
forward to your questions as we work to
protect our libraries and granted
Staters wallets and with that I ask if
questions representative
Gallagher so
um one
um one case along these lines that I've
read about recently has been the case of
um the internet archive
um being in uh legal conflicts with
Publishers um so due to similar
contracts about ebooks um
now I I'm wondering would this so would
this apply like just to local libraries
or say like what would the would would
the internet archive for example be able
to um make use of this law if they say
Incorporated in New Hampshire or um set
up like some sort of physical location
here something so thank you
representative to my knowledge the
internet archive would not be under the
scope of this law because it is not
Distributing ebooks and there's no fee
paid for the internet archive the
internet archive is a freely available
resource of uh scholarly articles that
have been posted online versus something
like uh the Sage portal which has a paid
subscription service that libraries use
to access
uh scholarly
articles libraries would still have to
pay for ebooks they're just doing so on
inequitable basis uh this bill does
Define what libraries are as obviously
we need to Define what a library is and
this bill does so it would include
research
institutions so they would still need to
pay for ebooks but do so on an equitable
basis but I don't believe it would count
research articles within it based on the
Kella thank you uh thank you for taking
the question it seems like the basis for
this bill is
fairness however um if if Publishers
decided that um they were no longer
going to
their their uh ebooks Perpetual licenses
if they they sold them decided to sell
them for you know you can only read this
three times and then um that's that's
all that you're getting with this fee
would then um your qualms about the
unfairness between the general public
and libraries be uh
assuaged
it would certainly put the public and
libraries on an equal basis but I would
say that then both are being equally
treated equally unfairly indeed this is
a bill about fairness Consumer
Protection Law is a matter of fairness
which is a traditional State concern to
protect its citizens in the matter of uh
consumer
affairs representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for uh taking my question
have you consulted with the the New
Hampshire Public
Library I've consulted with the New
Hampshire Public Library and also my
public library in Keen about this uh and
both have reflected the fact that they
are paying an exorbitant amount of money
on ebooks and would support this type of
Bill thank
you represent stavis thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
have you consulted with any University
libraries in the state on this question
I've consulted with Keane State Library
who is indicated support for the bill uh
we also see that uh public libraries
from other states which have introduced
similar bills have supported because
similar to what we see in public
libraries University libraries also get
hit with these similar fees uh this
would also again allow for a better uh
access to inter Library loans since most
libraries are part of the inter Library
Network this would allow for inter
Library lending at a better or more
Equitable inter Library lending since if
a library were to lend out a book
through IL that would count towards
their 26 not even giving it towards
their own patrons a followup question
followup followup thank you Mr
chair
um you'll have to excuse me but but this
is a committee that deals with the kind
of nuts and bolts details of local
Municipal County
government um I'm struggling to find
where where the contents of this bill
fits into the workings of local and
municipal
government uh thank you for your
question I was also surprised to see
that it was assigned to the committee
however I am not the speaker and don't
get to make those decisions it seems to
be a more natural fit for Commerce which
is where it has gone uh in other states
would it's been there however our public
libraries are controlled by
municipalities and also receive
Municipal dollars ultimately I would say
that this is not an issue of fairness
but an issue of Municipal dollars we are
wasting Municipal dollars by paying
exorbitant fees for ebooks and paying
those exorbitant fees repeatedly when
those books are available to Consumers
at a lesser rate and if those same
materials were purchased in paper they'd
be purchased for much less and
once representative kahill thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
good to see you again um did you consult
the Library Association did they have a
um an opinion on this the American
public the American Library Association
I've not consulted them but they've been
supportive of the bill in other states
this is also a revised version of the
bill from what was in 2022 in Maryland
to specifically taken out of the realm
of copyright into the realm of uh
contract law and the American public
Library Association is supportive of
language representative
majority thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh my
question goes right to Commerce but this
is here so I have to ask the question do
you have any idea how many different
companies are available for our
libraries to purchase these and if any
of those companies could just then say
no based on if this bill were to pass
and therefore leaving us in a in a
without the ability to provide those
books to to my knowledge there are five
major Publishers of consumer books um
and I actually one of them has already
said they don't want to offer ebooks in
general except for at a at a high rate
uh the difficulty with the book industry
is that for example if Michael cden were
to write a new book it would only be
available through that publisher whereas
in other Municipal contracts we can go
out and do a competitive bid that steel
is available through a number of of
vendors or even for pharmaceuticals you
can wait for a generic to come out there
will be no generic Michael Ken and that
that is the difficulty here is that we
we do have to purchase it through this
vendor U so they could potentially pull
it however litigation through press is a
very attractive means to say that we
don't wish to contract with the state
because we can't get our own way is very
unattractive to a business and would
become very unattractive very quickly
boycotts have a way to sway companies
very
lales yes uh thank you for taking my
question you prefaced your comments by
saying that libraries are forced to pay
a higher rate than the general
public if the general public wants a
scholarly uh book why wouldn't they just
way typically what we're talking about
with regards to ebooks are not scholarly
books scholarly books do tend to cost
more than your trade books so here we're
talking more D Vinci Code than we are
cell
biology uh if a consumer wanted to
purchase that they would typically go
online and buy that however if a
consumer wanted to access a a scholarly
book they may do so through a library
which may have it available for as an
eever and one of the primary reasons why
they may do so is that they can't afford
it that we see for example the academic
libraries do have e versions of academic
books available because they are
expensive for your average student many
of these books are now approaching $3
$400 that can be a lot for a struggling
student and this provides a means for
them to access needed academic materials
for for lust to be able to get the
education they need without having to
pay exorb anded publisher
fees thank you repr of kill thank you Mr
chair thank thank you for taking another
question do you do you see this
affecting the school libraries too um is
are they under a different rate plan the
the terms of the bill does include the
school libraries however for example the
high school libraries do not use ebooks
to the same extent as do our public
libraries just as a just as an example
the Keen Public Library which is my
local library lent out 39,000 ebooks uh
last year alone which is more than one
per per person uh you're certainly not
getting to that rate at the the Keen
High School library um they are using
the more as there is a transition to
tablets in the classroom but we're
much represent priest uh thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
being here um what are other states
doing about this and what are the
repercussions of their actions so we've
seen about a dozen states bring this
forward right now with many of them
still in deliberation uh Maryland was
the first state to pass this and I said
the uh the federal court did Strike It
Down for violating the supremacy clause
with regards to the federal contracts
Clause because the way that the bill was
worded that it prohibited the the sale
of books which is ostensibly a violation
of the federal contracts Clause that's
debatable but that's the way that it
went New York in the same year passed
the same bill and out of fear of also
being struck down uh Governor hoel
vetoed that bill deciding that they
would rather do a redraft then go to
federal court and face the same fate
Massachusetts right now uh has a bill
that is very similar to this with slight
wording differences in committee we also
see that uh our neighbors in uh RH
Island and Connecticut have a similar
Bill uh Virginia has a bill in committee
uh Hawaii has a bill in committee as
well as a handful of other states right
now so we're starting to see a movement
towards
this followup rep yes please place a
followup um so there hasn't been any
states that have been able to enact this
that has not been struck down as of yet
no because it's a it's a relatively new
issue okay again 2022 was the first time
that such a bill was passed and
unfortunately was struck down by the
away representative
yella thank you so um it seems
like your
um your position uh based on on prior
questions is that um if the um the
Publishers decide that this is is
unworkable but they are not required to
um have uh any offerings to libraries
for ebook ebook
purchases um as a way to avoid
uh avoid the ramifications of this to be
fair representative the Publishers
already aren't required to sell to the
questions I have one based on that last
answer Publishers are not required to
sell ebooks to libraries is that what
you meant a private company is not
required to sell a product to anybody
that's been The Stance of the Supreme
um Can the uh can a library go down to
uh local bookstore or online or whatever
and buy a hard copy paperback is there
anything that prevents that from
occurring yes so as I mentioned in my my
my opening remarks for paper copies that
is what book or excuse me libraries do
that if they want to buy a paper copy
they will typically go on to Amazon get
that put it into uh special binding for
the repeated use and it cost about as
much as we would purchas something on
Amazon 4 plus the additional binding fee
it is only for the ebooks where they are
locked up into the Monopoly that the
Publishers have right now thank you
representative yo thank you kind of
going back to representative Galler's uh
question about the internet AR archive
since they do have books on there and in
on line six te you uh define archive as
a library and so I'm just wondering
um can you clarify why you believe that
the internet archive would not be um
qualified under this if if they are
indeed an archive because the law can't
effect the internet Li the internet
archive doesn't exist in New Hampshire
Hampshire further
questions seeing none thank you for
introducing Bill and your commentary
thank you thank you committee we have
one uh other pink card so far if you
tend to speak on this make sure you have
Stewart and missart as I have been
little LAX in reminding people could you
please State at the beginning whether
you are for against or neutral on the
you is that on okay my name is Mary
Stewart I'm an assistant attorney
general for the consumer consum
protection and antitrust Bureau at the
Attorney General's office we are not
here to support or oppose the bill but
to point out a concern regarding
enforcement only so I uh would direct
your attention to the third page which
is section 202
C3 which is remedies violation of the
consumer protection act and there's
three sentences uh the first one of
violation in this chapter is considered
to be a violation of the consumer
protection act 358a and all remedies and
consumer
protection act are available for such
violations that's fine our concern is
the second sentence which says actions
May BR be brought by libraries Library
officers borrowers the attorney general
and then it says or pursuant to RSA 358
A4
um so our concern is is that the
reference to 358 A4 could arguably be
granting um administrative enforcement
authority to private parties which
historically has never happen in this
type of situation typically so the
consumer protection act has two remedy
Provisions one is 358 A4 which are the
administrative remedies that are
typically enforced by the Consumer
Protection Bureau those in include
injunctions uh civil
penalties um restitution and the ability
to request the court to appoint a
receiver and then there is a private
remedy section which is 358 A10 and uh
private parties can also Sue under the
consumer protection act they can receive
damages either actual or $1,000
statutory damages equable relief like an
injunction um and if the ACT is
intentional they can get double or
treble damages so our our only concern
is that reference to 358 A4 should
not um to not Grant to private citizens
questions
are there
questions you look like you have a
question representative
yella I'm surprised representative power
didn't didn't uh tear this sentence to
shreds with with grammar so um the um
the Oxford comma usage uh in this um
there's like borrows borrowers the
Attorney General um is just run on right
correct and so that also is a problem
so is that you you agree with that yeah
I agree there seems to be some
commas you know and missing in this
thank you
yes should be actions may be brought by
libraries it says actions May brought by
libraries we'll acknowledge that there
are issues with the com sentence missing
words further comments or questions uh
questions representative Brown thank you
Mr chairman U so in regard to RSA 358
A4 the only objection you really have to
this is excuse me the only objection you
really have to this is that the the
incorrect enforcement if this bill was
passed the way it is without that
reference then the Attorney General
could have enforced this based on being
the state as opposed to individuals is
that the point you were making yeah what
the it what it is intending to do is to
say violation is of of this bill or this
statute is a violation the consumer
protection act and the Attorney General
can enforce that and and would be able
to do that under the language of the
spill Our concern is and as could
private citizens so our only concern is
is that we don't want private citizens
to have administrative enforcement
Authority as well so it's just the it's
phrased thank you very much
okay further comments question uh
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you having no other pink cards uh we had
two individuals sign in the the
representative uh representative philio
who was Pro and Shelly husband who was
okay so with that we'll close the
hearing on
HB
FN so it looks like we are complete for
the day we had originally one other Bill
scheduled but that one the sponsor
pulled and retracted completely so we
are don't have that one to go on uh next
date as I spoke at the beginning for
those who weren't here we will meet I'll
go over the dates again for January we
will meet next Wednesday the
17th the following Wednesday the
30th and there's a possibility we may
throw in an extra day towards the end of
the two two weeks where we may do some
exing but that's undecided at this point
representative majority thank you Mr
chair are those hearing dates or those
will be hearing dates uh next week is
already set if you look in the uh as a
calendar route yet yeah I think I saw it
it should was it in well we we got a
notice I think it'll be in the calendar
this Thursday ex follow then at some
point at some point okay thank you
haven't got I haven't scheduled those
yet represent PRI thank you Mr chairman
I have a point of
clarification um there were several
bills today that might have some
amendments and I guess we will be using
our exact time to go over the Amendments
and will the public have any
amendments yes we will use the
exec to go over any amendments what I
would hope to see is the couple of bills
that we're talking about amendments that
those amendments would be
done by the
the uh the sponsors and as on one of
them I asked n if Katherine might be
able to get together and work that way
we have the amendments in advance and
they can be presented to us whether or
not we will have another public hearing
on those or not or if it'll just be
during an exec session that'll be
probably depend on content of the bill
but yes does that answer your
question
further
questions all right we'll see everybody
next
Wednesday
down
okay just because I want to meet the
people I haven't met
for